mitgeteilt dass heute die
Bundesministerin für Wohnen
Stadtentwicklung und Bauwesen klarer
Gallwitz zur Verfügung steht Frau
Bundesministerin sie haben jetzt das
Wort für die einleitenden Worte
denn dann meine sehr geehrten Damen und
Herren Abgeordnete herzlichen Dank für
Ihr Interesse an der regierungsbefragung
und die gute Gelegenheit die Diskussion
die wir gerade im Bauausschuss hatten
vorzuführen dass Bauministerium liegt
auf sehr ein sehr bewegtes Jahr zurück
wie wir glaube ich alle es war
gekennzeichnet zum einen von der großen
sozialen Frage des wohns die gerade
jetzt durch die gestiegene Nebenkosten
für viele Menschen das große Problem war
in diesem Jahr wir haben reagiert mit
einem
Heizkostenzuschuss das war das erste
Gesetz in dieser Legislaturperiode und
es folgt ein zweiter Heizkostenzuschuss
und dann die historisch größte Reform
des Wohngeldes das setzt natürlich
insbesondere in den Kommunen großer
Anstrengung voraus und sehr viele
Kommunen sind jetzt dabei und wir sind
sehr auf die müsstest dass es gelingt
diese große wohngeldreform auch an den
Staat zu bringen in vielen Kommunen wird
es möglich sein schon im Januar die
neuen Höchstsätze dann zu bezahlen Sie
wissen wir haben Kreis ausgeweitet
dreimal mehr Menschen bekommen doppelt
so viel Wohngeld das war ein wichtiger
Beitrag dafür dass die Menschen sich
weiterhin ihr Haus oder ihre Wohnung
leisten können ein ebenso wichtiger
Punkt war die deutlicher Erhöhung des
der Mittel die für den sozialen
Wohnungsbau zur Verfügung stehen sie
wissen wir kommen von drei Millionen
Sozialwohnungen sind jetzt in einer
Situation wo es nur noch eine Million
gibt und da haben wir gesagt wir müssen
massiv investieren in den sozialen
Wohnungsbau 14,5 Milliarden stehen dafür
zur Verfügung ein ganz wichtiger
Stabilisierungseffekt in dem Bereich
nächstes Jahr wird es weitergehen mit
dem sozialen Aspekt des wohns mit der
Schaffung eines Konzeptes zur
wohngemeinnützigkeit die ist dann
schafft das dauerhaft preiswerte
Wohnungen sozialgebundene Wohnungen am
Markt sind und ergänzt wird das Ganze
durch einen
Aktionsplan zur Bekämpfung der
Obdachlosigkeit der die Kommunen und die
Länder bei dieser großen Aufgabe
unterstützt dan so stehen wir im Bereich
des Bauens vor einer großen
Transformation das eine ist die
dekarbonisierung zum einen des
gebäudebereiches aber auch das Bereiches
der wärmewende und wir müssen natürlich
in Deutschland die Kapazitäten ausbauen
sie kennen die Zahlen wir hatten letztes
Jahr unter 300.000 Wohnungen die fertig
geworden sind die 400.000 das ist ja die
Benchmark die mein Haus vom ersten Tag
an verfolgt das ist das Ziel das noch
Fuß auf den Berechnungen die vor dem 24
Februar angestellt wurden aufgrund des
furchtbaren Krieges von Putin in der
Ukraine sind natürlich noch mal mehr
Menschen zu uns gekommen das müssen wir
einbeziehen das heißt wir müssen mit
aller Kraft auch wenn es jetzt noch
schwieriger geworden ist schneller bauen
und planen und hier haben wir zum einen
das Raumordnungsgesetz schon novelliert
um Planungsverfahren zu beschleunigen
aber heute morgen hat auch das Kabinett
die nächste Novelle des Baugesetzbuches
in Richtung Parlament gegeben nämlich
die Digitalisierung wir digitalisieren
die Bürgerbeteiligung wir verkürzen die
Fristen und wir machen zum Beispiel bei
geänderten Plänen die Beteiligung nur
noch zu den Änderungen und nicht mehr
zum kompletten Plan das sind viele
einzelne Schritte gerade auch im Ausbau
der erneuerbaren Energien wir haben
angefangen mit dem Wind Energie an
Landgesetz wo wir über das Baugesetz die
bessere Verbindlichkeit der Wind
Ausbauziele erreichen und auch Länder im
Süden motivieren Windräder zu errichten
Bayern hatten wir ja den schönen Umstand
dass da der Ministerpräsident und
zweifachminister bei der Einweihung
eines Windrades dabei waren es geht also
auch da voran und es geht weiter mit der
Baugesetzbuch Novelle damit wir zum
Beispiel ehemalige Tagebauflächen oder
auch Verkehrsflächen ein Autobahn nutzen
können und auch den Hochlauf von
Wasserstoff durch die Kombination von
Windenergie PV Energieanlagen mit
Elektro- und die Frage wie heizen wir in
Zukunft wird wichtig sein im nächsten
Jahr das werden wir intensiv miteinander
besprechen bei der Umsetzung der
viele und natürlich auch beim Gesetz zur
kommunalen wärmeplanung und ergänzt wird
das Ganze durch die Tatsache dass mein
Ministerium jetzt ab 1.1 zuständig sein
wird für die Neubauförderung und für die
Eigentumsförderung und entsprechende
Konzepte und entsprechendes Geld zur
Verfügung steht und wichtig ist dass wir
aber auch wissen dass wir im Bereich der
öffentlichen Gebäude einen großen
Investitionsbedarf haben da danke ich
dem Bundestag deshalb erneut auch große
mengengeldes 476 Millionen waren es
dieses Jahr 400 für den Sportbereich
sind noch mal nächstes Jahr da für die
Sanierung von Jugendeinrichtung von
Sporteinrichtungen von
Kultureinrichtungen und die große
Aufgabe die Anpassung der urbanenräume
an den Klimawandel die wird uns
begleiten auch bei der
baugesetzbuchnovelle da werden wir es
schaffen müssen das Baugesetzbuch was er
noch aus einer Phase kommt nach dem
Krieg wo man auf den Wiederaufbau
fokussierte Umzug ähm zu bauen und zu
sagen die große Herausforderung
heutzutage ist den bekannt zu erhalten
den Bestand zu sanieren nachzuverdichten
und unsere Städte fit und resilient zu
machen so
[Applaus]
viel Ihnen jetzt die regierungsbefragung
zu den einleitenden Ausführungen
Ausführungen und zum Geschäftsbereich
sowie zu den vorangegangenen
Kabinettssitzungen und mit den
allgemeinen Fragen und ich erteile das
Wort zur ersten Frage den Kollegen Dr
Jan Marco Luczak
frau Präsidentin vielen Dank Frau
Ministerin die FAZ hat gestern getitel
Deutschland steht vor dem Baustopp und
in diesem Artikel haben die Unternehmen
der Wohnungswirtschaft skizziert die
Lage auf dem Wohnungsmarkt und die Lage
ist wirklich dramatisch dort ist
skizziert worden dass reihenweise
Projekte storniert werden dass wir einen
dramatischen Einbruch der
genehmigungszahlen beim Neubau erleben
und dass die 400.000 Wohnungen die Sie
gerade auch angesprochen haben ja mehr
oder weniger nur Wunschdenken sind dass
das Realitätsverweigerung quasi ist dass
man etwa 250.000 Wohnungen vielleicht in
diesem Jahr schaffen wird im nächsten
Jahr wahrscheinlich nur noch 200.000 und
das hat natürlich was mit der Ukraine zu
tun hat aber auch etwas damit zu tun
dass seine Unternehmen dass die
Regierung in diese schwierige Situation
Öl ins Feuer gehst weil sie die
Baustandards erhöhen weil sie die Kosten
damit in die Höhe treiben und
gleichzeitig die Förderung reduzieren
deswegen möchte ich Sie und die
Bundesregierung Fragen nach ihrer
Verantwortung wir reagieren sie auf
diesen Vorwurf dass sie Öl Gießen was
möchten Sie tun damit es wieder vorwärts
geht bei den wohnungsbauzielen und ich
möchte gerne auch eine konkrete Zahl
haben was erwarten sie denn das im
kommenden Jahr tatsächlich an
wohnungsneubauge sieht dass sie da eine
Zahl nennen jenseits der 400.000
Ministerin sie können Antworten
ja also grundsätzlich versuche ich es
immer zu vermeiden Öl ins Feuer zu
gießen das ist nämlich nicht zu
empfehlen ansonsten wissen Sie die
Rahmenbedingungen sind schwierig und es
geht darum dass wir die Kapazität
ausweiten weil selbst im letzten Jahr
als wir noch keinen Krieg hatten als die
Zinsen historisch niedrig waren und als
wir ganz ganz viel Geld in die
neuauförderung gesteckt haben sind wir
ja unter dem eigenen Ziel nämlich damals
375.000 Wohnungen zu bauen von
Bauminister Horst Seehofer
runtergelaufen auf unter 300.000
deswegen gehe ich nicht davon aus dass
es in diesem Jahr mit den wesentlich
schwierigen grabenbedingungen zu einer
sprunghaften Erhöhung um 25% der
baukapazitäten gekommen ist in der Tat
wir werden die 400.000 dieses Jahr
erreichen das was wir machen es eine
ganz stabile Förderung 14,5 Milliarden
in den sozialen Wohnungsbau damit die
neuen Wohnung nicht auch noch das
Mietniveau in unseren Städten anheizen
sondern Beitrag leisten dass es runter
geht und das zweite ist die neue
wohngemeinnützigkeit eine
genossenschaftsförder wie wir angefangen
haben und die 1,1 Milliarden für die
Neubauförderung und 190 Maßnahmen des
Bündnisses bezahlbarer Wohnraum weil wir
natürlich auch die Länder brauchen
gerade bei der Frage der Vereinfachung
der Bauordnung der Angleichung der
Bauordnung
vielen Dank Frau Ministerin sie im am
Ende des Bündnis für bezahlbaren
Wohnraum angesprochen in der Tat 187
Maßnahmen wie erklären sie sich denn
eigentlich dass die Wohnungswirtschaft
17 Verbände zentrale Akteure auf dem
Wohnungsmarkt nur sechs Wochen sechs
Wochen nachdem die Ergebnisse von
monatelang Verhandlungen präsentiert
worden sind dass die einen dramatischen
hilfebruch gestartet haben gerufen haben
wir brauchen jetzt einen neuen
entschiedenen Kraftakt wo er ganz
offensichtlich die Einschätzung dort ist
dass das was im Bild
ist das bedeutet gerufen hat dass wir
das ganze machen müssen offensichtlich
fehlt es ja dort an Durchschlagskraft
bauen das Chefsache das sieht man in
dieser Regierung erstens weil es ein
baumministerium gibt und das Bündnis der
bündnisprozess für bezahlbaren Wohnraum
der Pfand ja im Kanzleramt statt und der
wird regelmäßig fortgeführt jedes Jahr
wird es einen bündnistag geben und das
war interessanter Zeitpunkt dieser
Veröffentlichung es war ja am Ende der
Haushaltsberatung die waren vorbei aber
an dem Tag wo zum Beispiel das
Jahressteuergesetz auch gerade durch die
Beratung des Deutschen Bundestages noch
mal deutlich verbessert wurden und wir
die AfA Anhörung vorgezogen haben zum
ersten ersten und eine sonderfahrer für
ih 40 Neubauten gemacht haben insofern
widerspricht sich das nicht vieles was
in diesem papierverbände Papier steht
z.B die Förderung dass er jeden Abend
die das sage ich vom ersten Tag meiner
Amtszeit an
und ich habe zwei Nachfragen aus anderen
Fraktionen einmal der Kollege Fürst von
der FDP
viel vielen
Frau Ministerin vielen Dank nachdem der
Herr Kollege luxagen
auf diesen Verbände Papier wir hören uns
natürlich alle dass die Bauindustrie
besorgt ist wir sehen das ja auch
tatsächlich in den stornierungszahlen
der bauklimaindex ist Ifo-Instituts
kennt nur eine Richtung die geht
tendenziell nach unten trotzdem muss man
feststellen dass das produktpapier zu
einer komischen Zeit kam weil danach das
Jahr Steuergesetz verabschiedet wurde
deswegen würde mich mal ihre Meinung
interessieren von den Forderungen
erstellt wurden wie viele denn jetzt
tatsächlich noch gelöst werden müssen
es akustisch nicht ganz verstanden
Satz es tut mir leid
also dieses Verbänden das ist Verbände
Papier auf das her dr Luczak abgestellt
hat es enthält ja viele Forderungen die
zum einen vor dem Jahressteuergesetz
erhöht erhoben wurden durch das einige
Forderungen abgedeckt wurde deswegen
wäre jetzt die Nachfrage an Sie als
verantwortliche Ministerin im bauen was
was ist jetzt noch in der Pipeline um
die anderen Anforderungen die anderen
Positionen abzuarbeiten und was hat sich
ihrer Meinung nach weiteres erledigt in
diesem Bände Verbände Papier drin
also im Kern sind es ja ein ganzes
Maßnahme Bündel das eines die Frage wie
viel Geld geben wir als Staat für die
Förderung aus da will ich mich jetzt
nicht wiederholen welche Instrumente wir
eingesetzt haben sowohl direktzuschüsse
über den sozialen Wohnungsbau
genossenschaftsförderung aber auch
abschreibungsfragen über das von Ihnen
angesprochene Gesetz und das andere sind
die Rahmenbedingungen das heißt wie viel
Vorschriften machen wir und wie schnell
sind wir beim Planen und genehmigen und
da habe ich auch gesagt sind wir gerade
dabei das Baugesetzbuch zu ändern aber
es gibt natürlich auch noch die ganzen
großen Vorhaben im Bereich der Planungs-
und genehmigungsbeschleunigung inklusive
Nationalisierung
soweit die Antwort der Ministerin auf
den Kollegen Fürst der noch eine
Nachfrage stellen kann
also nicht wir Sie mit den Verbänden
sind sie im Gespräch mit den beteiligten
Verbänden über die Abarbeitung der 187
Maßnahmen weil der DR Luca ja auch
darauf abgestellt hat und weil auch
teilweise diese Maßnahmen sich wieder
finden in diesem Verbände Papier und
wenn sie in dieser Diskussion sind wie
sie da momentan Priorisierung aus
angesichts der Dramatik können wir uns
nicht leisten dass man das erstmal das
eine bearbeitet und dann das andere wir
versuchen sämtliche Maßnahmen im
bündnisprozess in Arbeitsgruppen in den
unterschiedlichen Strukturen
voranzutreiben und das unterscheidet
dieses Bündnis ja von Vorgängermodellen
dass wir es nicht belassen bei dem einen
Tag im Kanzleramt sondern dass wir ein
kontinuierlichen Arbeitsprozess haben
mit einem Evaluationsbericht jedes Jahr
einmal und da sind natürlich dicke
Bretter wenn Sie die Angleichung der
Bauordnung ansehen oder die Kostenfolge
implementation im Normungsprozess
insofern wird es etwas ständig Aufgabe
ist das baumministeriums zu schauen
welche Maßnahmen können wir machen um
bauen einfacher und schneller in
Deutschland zu machen
vielen dank der nächste Fragesteller
hier noch in diese Runde ist Ulrich
lange
Ulrich lange aus der Unionsfraktion
stellt die nächste Frage
Frau Ministerin sie haben sich angeblich
zum Ziel gesetzt mehr Wohnraum zu
schaffen sie haben das
Jahressteuergesetz von angesprochen
gleichzeitig haben sie mehrfach zum
Ausdruck gebracht das nicht jede
Generation selber bauen soll und kann
durch die Hintertür haben Sie jetzt eine
Erhöhung der Erbschaftssteuer
beschlossen für welchen konkreten Betrag
der
Erbschaftssteuer Freibetrag setzen Sie
sich ein damit die nächste Generation im
eigenen Heim leben kann damit es
zumindest vererbt werden kann wenn sie
von nicht bauen soll
ja sie spielen wahrscheinlich auf die
Änderung der Immobilienbewertung an das
ist ja eine Leistung meines geschätzten
Vorgängers Horst Seehofer gewesen dieses
wirklich komplette Regelwerk an in
Anschluss an einen Gerichtsurteil des
Verfassungsgerichtes anzugehen und
ansonsten ist es so die Erbschaftssteuer
kommt den Ländern zugute deswegen mache
ich mir jetzt nicht einen schlanken Fuß
und sage von mir aus können wir da auf
Einnahmen verzichten sondern wir bieten
den Ländern an wenn es ein
Regelungsbedarf gibt in diesem Bereich
dass wir uns dem annehmen werden und
nicht verschließen
und ja eine Möglichkeit der Nachfrage
Frau Ministerin es geht ganz konkret um
den Freibetrag bei der Erbschaftssteuer
das ist ein Bundesgesetz setzen Sie sich
für dieses Bundesgesetz selber ein oder
machen Sie sich doch den schlanken Fuß
über die Länder für welche Summe sind
sie konkret
ja ich finde ehrlich gesagt man kann ja
nicht Politik machen nach dem Motto ich
bin dafür und andere müssen es bezahlen
insofern habe ich das Verfahren
geschildert das ist
ja auch so dass ich als bauministerin
ganz großes Interesse habe dass wir
dieses Jahressteuergesetz schnell auch
dann in Kraft setzen können weil die
Vergünstigung die dieses Parlament
erstritten hat gerade die Anhörung der
AfA von zwei auf drei Prozent und die
sonderafar für besonders ökologische
Gebäude die werden dringend gebraucht in
der Bauindustrie deswegen hoffe ich dass
wir da über die Parteigrenzen hinweg zu
einer schnellen Einkommen
vielen Dank dann sehe ich keine weitere
Frage jetzt mir dann ist die nächste
angemeldete Fragestellerin für Bündnis
90 die Grünen Anja Liebert
sehr geehrte Frau Ministerin meine Frage
bezieht sich auf das Thema was sie in
ihrer Einführung auch angesprochen haben
nämlich das Thema Hitze Klimaanpassung
wir haben nach diesem Sommer der
Extremwetter und insbesondere auch nach
der Flutkatastrophe im Juli 2021
festgestellt dass wir in Deutschland in
vielen Bereichen noch nicht Klima
angepasst bauen die Städte und Gemeinden
haben da einen sehr großen Nachholbedarf
vor allem auch was Hochwasser
angepasstes bauen und Maßnahmen für mehr
Klimaschutz in der Stadtentwicklung
angehen wir haben das Bundesprogramm zur
Anpassung urbaner Räume an den
Klimawandel aber unsere Frage geht dahin
was haben wir noch darüber hinaus an
Möglichkeiten für grün und Freiflächen
für Klimaanpassung und hitzeanpassung in
der Zukunft was sind da ihre
Vorstellungen in der nächsten Zeit wie
können wir unsere Städte und Gemeinden
besser vor
extremwetterereignissen schützen
[Applaus]
die Reaktionen auf die geänderten
Temperaturen das sind sicherlich nicht
nur bauliche Reaktionen gerade was
hitzeplanung anbelangt muss man auch
über die Struktur von kühlen Orten reden
über die Alarmierung der Bevölkerung bei
eine Sensibilität auch im medizinischen
Bereich baulich wird das eine der großen
Herausforderungen sein bei der Novelle
des Baugesetzbuches dass man die
Klimaanpassung mitdenkt bei sämtlichen
bauplanverfahren dass man frische Luft
zuschneiden mit plant dass man Hitze
Inseln versucht zu verhindern und dass
man zum Beispiel wir werden das
Vorschlagen
klimasanierungsgebiete macht so wie wir
jetzt im denkmalschutzbereich
Sanierungsgebiete haben weil wir
natürlich eine riesentransformation
haben im Bereich Verkehrswende
wärmewende das wird die Struktur der
Städte ganz stark angehen und wir müssen
verstehen dass wir das alles nur im
Quartier denken können und dass die
Summe wichtiger ist als nur die
einzelnen Häuser zu betrachten weil
gerade wenn sie starkregender eigenen
aber auch Hitze Inseln das ist etwas was
sie nicht am Haus selber sanieren können
sondern wo sie ein quartiersansatz
brauchen und das werden wir über das
Baugesetzbuch aber natürlich auch über
die kommunale wärmeplanung nächstes Jahr
gestalten
sie haben die Möglichkeit einer
Nachfrage
ja vielleicht in dem Zusammenhang gibt
es ja noch den Punkt wie schaffen wir es
auch im Gebäude Sektor die Klimaziele zu
erreichen und auch stärker CO2 angepasst
zu bauen würden sie das auch in einen
Zusammenhang setzen mit dem Klima
angepassten mit der Klima angepassten
Stadtentwicklung
also das Qualitätssiegel nachhaltiges
Gebäude aus unserem Haus ist ja genau
dieser breitere Ansatz ja nicht mehr nur
fokussiert auf die Energieeffizienz
sondern auch noch die Materialien in den
Blick nimmt aber auch den
Flächenverbrauch und deren Anreize zum
Beispiel Flächen sparen zu bauen so dass
wir verstehen müssen dass die Lösung
nicht darin bestehen kann möglichst
hochtechnische Lösungen zu schaffen
sondern dass wir die gesamten
Treibhausgasemissionen des
gebäudebereiches in den Blick nehmen
müssen sowohl für den Heizbereich als
auch für den Gebäudebereich an sich und
natürlich auch durch die digitalen
Ressourcen passt das was wir jetzt schon
haben an Ressourcen viel stärker als
bisher auch in die Kreislaufwirtschaft
einbringen
vielen Dank und ich habe eine Nachfrage
von Emmi zäunung
ja sehr geehrte Frau Ministerin zum
Thema Klima gehört und sie haben es
angesprochen zum Beispiel ja auch das
Thema luftschneisen in Quartieren und es
ist ja da schon gebaut worden also das
heißt wir müssen in die Richtung
Entsiegelung gehen und deswegen da die
konkrete Frage was tun Sie ganz konkret
dazu dafür dass es eben eine verstärkte
Programme beispielsweise beim Thema
Flächenentsiegelung geben kann beim
Thema Flächen Kreislaufwirtschaft was
sind da ihre Pläne für die Zukunft
das eine ist dass wir das
Raumordnungsgesetz jetzt ja novelliert
haben um entsprechend auch diese
Planungen mit zu beschleunigen das
andere ist über das Baugesetzbuch dass
wir genau uns anschauen können wo wir
zum Beispiel über die Bauplanung noch
stärker als bisher das ganze Thema
wasserversicherung in der Stadt
planen können das wird ganz wichtig sein
wir haben Prognosen das insbesondere im
Süden Deutschland aber auch in
Nordrhein-Westfalen die
Wahrscheinlichkeit für starkregender zu
steigt und wir prüfen gerade ob wir dann
eben noch ein individuelles Programm für
die Hausbesitzer machen die ihre Häuser
dann an besser als bisher zum Beispiel
ein Starkregenereignisse anpassen können
und sie haben die Möglichkeit einer
Nachfrage
wie wollen sie dann weil das ja
natürlich dann auch Aufgabe der Kommunen
ist ganz konkret unsere Kommunen
entlasten um eben Entsiegelung auf den
Weg zu bringen wir wissen die Baupreise
sind gestiegen es ist kaum oder sehr
sehr schwierig möglich überhaupt noch
eben in Wohnungsbau beispielsweise zu
gehen also dann Grünflächen anzulegen
und so weiter das kostet natürlich Geld
also was wollen Sie konkret auf den Weg
bringen um Kommunen dabei zu helfen eben
Flächen auch tatsächlich zu entsiegeln
zum einen ganz klassische
Städtebauförderung dient dazu zum
Beispiel auch Flächen zu entsiegeln das
andere ist dass wir zum Beispiel über
das Windenergie an Landgesetz ja auch
die Möglichkeit geschaffen haben das
Länder untereinander Verträge schließen
können so dass man in einem Land Flächen
spart und dem anderen Land zusätzlich
Wind energieflächen ausweist und dann
weiß ich auch darauf hin dass
flächenspazier ist nicht ein
flächenspazier von dem Bauministerium
sondern der gesamten Bundesregierung und
Steffi Lemke hat einen großen Beitrag
auch zu Renaturierung leisten können
indem sie zum Beispiel über ihrem
moorschutzprogramm aber auch für die
Milliarden für die Stärkung der
Biodiversität genau das machen kann
nämlich Flächen die nicht mehr gebraucht
werden zu ähm renaturieren
vielen Dank ich sehe keine Nachfrage
mehr dann kommen wir zum nächsten doch
ach der hallo Entschuldigung
Jan marco lucczak ist das vielen vielen
Dank Frau Ministerin sie hatten gerade
das flächensparziel angesprochen das
haben sie jetzt in Interviews in den
letzten Tagen ja auch immer als Grund
dafür genannt dass zukünftige
Generationen keine neuen
Einfamilienhäuser mehr bauen wollen sie
haben gesagt das wird nicht gehen
sondern wir müssen eben Flächen
einsparen und sie wollen sich deswegen
auf den Bestand konzentrieren ähm mich
hat das soweit ein bisschen verwundert
ihre Aussage weil sie ja ein Konzept für
die Eigentumsförderung jetzt in
Eckpunkten zumindestens vorgestellt
haben ist leider noch nicht in Kraft da
warten wir noch drauf aber in Eckpunkten
bei diesem Konzept ist es aber so dass
gerade die Eigentumsbildung im Bestand
was er gerade in Ballungsgebieten in
großen Städten der Fall ist dort kaufen
die Leute ja keine neuen Wohnung und
auch bauen auch keine Einfamilienhäusern
sondern sie kaufen bestandswohnung das
wird nach ihren Eckpunkten aber gerade
nicht gefördert und deswegen wundert
mich dass sie setzen sich ja jedenfalls
den Worten nach immer für
Eigentumsbildung aus aber an dieser
Stelle ist eine große Lehrstelle es
klappt einfach nicht und es ist eine
offener Widerspruch zu dem was sie im
Interview gesagt haben dass man in den
Bestand eigentlich gehen müsste
Frau Ministerin
ja zum einen bin ich ja nicht alleine in
dieser Bundesregierung und sie wissen
die
neue antwortet die bauministerin und die
bestandsförderung die Verantwortung
Robert Habeck und bei aller weiten
Interpretation von Neubau ist ein Haus
bestand einfach kein Neubau deswegen
gibt es diese Trennung zwischen den zwei
Ansätzen und die Union hat ja auch im
letzten plenumtreffen ganz treffend
herausgearbeitet dass der Anteil der
Sanierungsförderung doch deutlich über
dem der
neubau-förderung liegt was die Summe des
Geldes anbelangt und ansonsten ist es
wichtig dass es kein entweder oder gibt
es wird natürlich immer in der Zukunft
auch Neubau geben aber bis auch bereits
jetzt ist natürlich die überwiegende
Mehrzahl der Eigentumsbildung im Bestand
und der die Möglichkeit der Nachfrage ja
sehr gerne mich verwundert dass ein
bisschen Frau Ministerin bei in der Tat
es gibt natürlich die Neubauförderung
auf der einen Seite und es gibt das was
Robert Habeck macht bei sich da geht es
um den Bestand richtig aber es geht um
dieser Nieren des Bestandes das hat
nichts rein gar nichts mit
Eigentumsbildung zu tun das heißt das
was die Bundesregierung macht ist auf
der einen Seite Sanierung im Bestand
fördern und den Neubau fördern aber die
Eigentumsbildung im Bestand wo sie
gerade selber gesagt haben das ist der
zentrale Baustein wo die Leute in die
eigene vier Wände kommen wo die Menschen
von dir träumen da passiert gar nichts
bei dieser Bundesregierung
ganz lebenspraktisch ist es in der Regel
so dass wenn Sie einen Bestandsgebäude
erwerben dass sie dann auch einen hohen
Sanierungsbedarf haben um es für sich
anzupassen und deswegen war es zum
Beispiel auch sehr gut dass jetzt das
wohnriester-programm was ja
Vermögensbildung auch unterstützen soll
geöffnet wurde auch für die energetische
Sanierung
vielen Dank einen kleinen Hinweis Herr
Bernhard sie sind eigentlich auch der
nächste reguläre Fragesteller
Kraft Entschuldigung genau Herr Kraft
dann sind sie jetzt dran Entschuldigung
bitte ich hatte sie kurz verwechselt ja
ich weiß es gibt auch noch eine
Nachfrage ja alles gut wir machen eine
Runde Nachfragen es gibt jeder hat die
Möglichkeit von Nachfragen wie wie
diejenigen sich melden werden sie dran
genommen Fräulein und dann machen
ordentliches Verfahren hier
ja kein Problem Frau bauministerin sie
hatten gerade im Rahmen der Moschee
Strategie vom Ministerin Lemke über die
Renaturierung von Flächen die nicht mehr
gebraucht werden und ich möchte von
Ihnen jetzt bitte konkret wissen welche
Flächen in Deutschland denn nicht mehr
nicht mehr gebraucht werden um ihr Wort
zu zitieren sind es die den [ __ ] und
sümpfenabgang in ackerbauflächen sind
die dem [ __ ] den Bauflächen in
Deutschland welche sind denn die Flächen
die in Deutschland nicht mehr gebraucht
werden
fragt Rainer Kraft aus der afd-fraktion
das war sprachlich nicht ganz präzise
weil diese Flächen werden zum Beispiel
für die naturschutzgebraucht
und die Möglichkeit einer Nachfrage sie
sagen also die moschee-strategie der
Bundesregierung wird sie auch entlang
der Flüsse und der den dortigen Auen die
zu landwirtschaftliche Fläche umgebaut
worden sind ausschließlich auf Flächen
beziehen die nur für den Umweltschutz
gebraucht werden und nicht für
wohnraumverkehr für die wald- und
Forstwirtschaft und sonstige
landwirtschaftlichen Nutzflächen ist das
korrekt habe ich Sie richtig verstanden
also man sollte ein Moor nicht
unterschätzen wir sind gerade ein sehr
intensiven Austausch zum Beispiel über
die Frage inwiefern wir das lange Gras
was auf diesen sehr extensiv
bewirtschafteten Flächen wächst auch
nehmen kann um eines der großen Probleme
zu lösen nämlich wie kriegen wir
eigentlich nachhaltige Dämmstoffe hin da
gibt es gerade in Mecklenburg-Vorpommern
schon ganz Interessenten interessante
Ansätze insofern heißt es nicht dass
Flächen die gut für die Natur sind dass
sie nicht automatisch auch auf andere
Art als bisher von den Menschen genutzt
werden können
vielen Dank und dann habe ich die
nächste Nachfrage von der Kollegin
Bündnis 90 Sekunden vielen Dank Frau
Ministerin dass sie auch dieses Beispiel
genannt haben wie man Flächen sinnvoll
mehrfach nutzen kann jetzt hatten wir
zum Teil den Eindruck bei den Fragen
dass man im Bestand kein Wohnraum
schaffen kann aber das ist ja nicht so
und deswegen frage ich Sie welche
Maßnahmen ergreifen Sie planen Sie im
Rahmen des Baugesetzbuch zur ergreifen
um Aufstockung und Umnutzung und bestand
zu erleichtern vielen Dank
eine sind rechtliche Rahmenbedingungen
wir wollen es leichter machen dass man
Dachgeschosse umbauen und ausbauen kann
und da ist auch erleichtern dass man
Büroflächen zum Beispiel umnutzen kann
in Wohnungen weil da ist ja schon ganz
viel graue Energie gebunden und das
andere ist dass unsere Bundesstiftung
Baukultur jetzt z.B ein Kulturbericht
ein baukulturbericht veröffentlicht hat
der das Thema Umbau zentral macht weil
das natürlich auch ganz häufig eine
Frage ist denke ich automatisch wenn ich
etwas brauche erstmal ein Abriss oder
Neubau oder aber schaue ich auch an was
kann man eigentlich nach nutzen und wir
werden weil das Geld auf diese Fragen
natürlich auch wichtig ist die
Honorarordnung der Ingenieure und
Architekten so ändern dass auch die
intellektuelle Leistung des Umbaus
entsprechend honoriert wird und sie sind
die Möglichkeit danach folgen
vielen Dank Frau Ministerin ja
Flächenverbrauch wichtiges Thema gerade
deswegen ist es ja wichtig Prioritäten
zu setzen kann man weniger versiegeln
will die Bundesregierung sagt 400.000
Wohnungen davon ich sage aus meiner
Sicht nur 100.000 soziale Wohnungen aber
auch von diesem Themen von diesem Ziel
was sie jährlich ausgegeben haben sind
wir meilenweit entfernt wir haben in
diesem Jahr im letzten Jahr nur 23.000
Sozialwohnungen geschaffen und die 14,5
Milliarden neu gebaut die 14,5
Milliarden die sie jetzt erwähnt haben
die beziehen sich ja nicht auf ein Jahr
bis der Deutsche Mieterbund und noch wir
fordern sondern auf fünf Jahre das ist
in diesem Jahr gerade mal eine
Verdoppelung der Mittel und da ist
wirklich meine Frage ob sie glauben dass
sie mit diesen Mittel Einsatz eine
Vervierfachung der aktuellen Zahlen
erreichen wollen wie kann das mit einer
guten Verdoppelung der Mittel überhaupt
gelingen bei steigenden Baupreisen das
ist doch völlig unrealistisch
ja herzlichen Dank für die Frage sie
wissen ja dass der soziale Wohnungsbau
in der Zuständigkeit der Länder liegt
wir geben einen erheblichen Zuschuss mit
14,5 Milliarden die Länder kofinanzieren
das und sie wissen auch dass es viele
Länder gibt die deutlich mehr als die 30
Prozent geforderten
Kofinanzierungsanteil stemmen und wir
müssen natürlich auch sehen wir haben
jahrelang zu wenig investiert in den
sozialen Wohnungsbau das ist ein System
was anlaufen muss deswegen erhöhen wir
jedes Jahr die Förderung um 500
Millionen weil es bringt natürlich auch
nichts wenn ich die Ländern jetzt Geld
gebe und die können das aufgrund ihrer
Haushaltssituation nicht abrufen und sie
sehen flächendeckend in vielen
Bundesländern eine deutliche Anpassung
nach oben der Fördersätze des sozialen
Wohnungsbaus und nächstes Jahr kommt
noch die 500 Millionen Scheibe für das
junge Wohnen für Azubi Wohnheime und
Studentenwohnheime hinzu
sie haben die Möglichkeit der Nachfrage
dass diese Möglichkeit würde ich sehr
gerne nutzen denn ich glaube viele
Menschen haben wenig Verständnis dafür
wenn der Bund sagt die Länder sind
verantwortlich haben wir hier vor ein
paar Jahren das Grundgesetz gemeinsam
geändert also mit Ausnahme der AFD damit
der Bund auch wieder in den
Mitverantwortung für den sozialen
Wohnungsbau kommt und das Grundproblem
das wissen wir als
wohnungspolitikerinnen alle ist es ja
Jahr für Jahr die Bindungen ausfallen
bei den Sozialwohnungen das heißt wir
hatten im letzten Jahr trotz einem
Neubau von 23.9 Wohnungen unterm Strich
ein Minus von 27.000 Sozialwohnungen das
heißt wir brauchen ein neues Prinzip
einmal Sozialwohnung immer Sozialwohnung
und was wollen Sie tun damit dieses
auslaufende Bindungen auch für die
bereits bestehenden Sozialwohnungen
unterbunden werden kann
wir werden dazu im März Eckpunkte
vorlegen für eine neue
wohngemeinnützigkeit die genau das
beinhaltet was sie sich wünschen nämlich
dauerhaft sozial gebundene Wohnungen
und die letzte Nachfrage Herr
schießanowski
besten Dank meine Kolleginnen leider hat
das gerade schon angesprochen den
sozialen Wohnungsbau und ich will
einleiten noch einmal hervorheben dass
wir hier ja und das hat die Frau
Ministerin in ihren einleitenden Worten
auch bereits getan ja
rekordinvestitionen des 2026 auf den Weg
bringen von 14,5 Milliarden Euro und ich
glaube auch das ist ein ganz zentral
wichtiger Schwerpunkt den das neue
baumministerium hier setzt deswegen
erlaube ich mir auch noch mal die
Nachfrage tiefer gehen wie denn der
Sachstand der Gespräche mit den Ländern
für mehr sozialen Wohnraum ist
Timo shisanowski aus der SPD-Fraktion
stellte diese Frage gerade in den
Verhandlungen für die Scheibe im
nächsten Jahr für 23 sowohl was die
klassische Verwaltungsvereinbarung als
auch die zusätzliche
Verwaltungsvereinbarung für Azubi wohnen
und studentenwohnen anbelangt ich bin
sehr optimistisch dass wir das jetzt in
den nächsten Tagen abschließen können
und die Verwaltungsvereinbarung an die
Länder geben die dann in Kraft tritt
wenn er denn alle Länder das
unterschrieben an den Bund
zurückgeschickt haben und wie gesagt sie
sehen das selber bei sich auch in den
Bundesländern aller Orten fängt man an
auch die Förderkonditionen für den
sozialen Wohnungsbau deutlich nach oben
zu verbessern und es wurde sich ja in
Föderalismusreform entschieden dass die
Länder die Verantwortung tragen weil die
Bedingungen vor Ort was gebraucht wird
wirklich sehr unterschiedlich sind und
dann die Möglichkeit danach Frage
weil jetzt so ja der Faktor Zeit auch
ganz entscheidend ist erlaube ich mir
die Nachfrage wie sie gedenken die
Prozesse denn insbesondere zu
beschleunigen auch für den sozialen
Wohnungsbau
dass wir die Gesetzesnovelle des
Baugesetzbuches die ich gerade
vorgestellt habe dass wir Umplanung
schneller ermöglichen jetzt auch in gut
beraten weil das ist zum Beispiel etwas
was wir sehen das Projekt Entwickler von
frei finanzierten Wohnungsbau umplanen
wollen auch Sozialwohnungen was ich
erstmal begrüße und hier ist es
natürlich dann einfacher wenn man nur
diesen Teil des B-Planes ändert und
ansonsten den restlichen noch mal
anhören muss dass man dann schnell auch
diese Bebauungspläne ändern kann das
sind ganz praktischer Beitrag dazu
ansonsten sind die Länder freiwillige
Mittel des Bundes einzusetzen wie sie es
aus ihrer Sicht in dem Bedürfnissen
ihrer Bundesländer für sinnvoll einen
schätzen
vielen Dank dann ist der nächste
reguläre und angemeldete Fragesteller
Markt Bernhard
Marc Bernhard aus der afd-fraktion
stellt die nächste Frage die ihr Ziel
von 400.000 neuen Wohnungen werden sie
ja wohl nicht erreichen pro Jahr dieses
Jahr werden es knapp vielleicht 250.000
werden nächstes Jahr vielleicht weniger
wie 200.000 gleichzeitig fehlen zwei
Millionen bezahlbare Wohnungen und ihr
Bündnis für Wohnraum haben wir ja schon
gehört ist eigentlich schon gescheitert
weil es eigentlich die völlig falschen
Maßnahmen macht weil es geht nicht um
planungsbeschleunigung im Wesentlichen
sondern es geht darum die Menschen
können nicht mehr bezahlen deswegen wird
nicht mehr gebaut und sie machen auf der
einen Seite zu wenig Förderung weil sie
fördern gerade mal den eigenen des
Eigenheim mit einer Milliarde Euro das
sind gerade mal 3000 € pro Wohnung ist
nicht mal ein Prozent des Kaufpreises
oder des Preises und machen auf der
anderen Seite des wohnen aber sehr sehr
viel teurer beispielsweise einfach durch
die Einführung des eh 55 Standards ab
nächstem Jahr dadurch werden Wohnungen
gebaut die sich 80% der Menschen in
Deutschland gar nicht mehr leisten
können die Miete nicht mehr zahlen
können und deshalb die Frage was wollen
Sie denn wie wollen Sie das jetzt
konkret schaffen 400.000 bezahlbare
Wohnungen herzustellen in absehbarer
Zeit dass die pro Jahr gebaut werden
also wie viel dieses Jahr tatsächlich
gebaut wird das werden wir mein nächsten
Jahres wissen wenn die Fertigstellung
Statistik vorliegt und ich weise darauf
hin dass dieses Jahr ziemlich große
Milliarden Summen in den Neubau gesteckt
worden durch die wg-förderung die wir
von der alten Bundesregierung übernommen
hatten und wir sehr genau analysieren
werden ob das eher ein Preiseffekt hat
oder tatsächlich zur
kapazitätsauswertung führte und bei eh
55 gibt es jetzt auch ein Gutachten was
ganz klar sagt er 55 ist über die
Strecke des Hauses insgesamt über die
Lebenszeit rentierlich weil man
entsprechend dann auch Energie einspart
insofern sich nicht dass er 55 jetzt den
Bau so verteuert das was wir vorhaben
ist was ich gerade erzählt habe
planungsbeschleunigung weil längere
Planungs- und Bauphasen natürlich
Kostensteigerung mit sich bringen
deswegen gibt es sehr Wohlen
Zusammenhang wir werden eine sehr
stabile Förderung machen um sozialen
Wohnungsbau wir arbeiten an der
wohngemeinnützigkeit und viele andere
Maßnahmen mehr
ich habe die Möglichkeit eine Nachfrage
ja neben der reinen Zahl der Wohnung ist
natürlich auch wichtig ich habe es
vorher schon gesagt dass die auch
bezahlbar sind und jetzt wollen sie ja
CO2-Ausstoß bis 2030 und 50 Prozent
reduzieren und wenn wir jetzt hier Klima
Sofortprogramm anschaut dann geht es da
mal hauptsächlich darum immer massivere
und kostenspieler der Maßnahmen auf der
einen Seite zu machen also die Kosten zu
erhöhen und dann führen Sie klar noch in
ihrem Klima Sofortprogramm aus dass sie
ihre Klimaziele überhaupt nur erreichen
können durch einen massiven Anstieg der
Energiepreise und da frage ich sie jetzt
mit diesen Plänen wie wollen Sie dafür
sorgen dass wohnen in Zukunft endlich
wieder bezahlbar wird ich kann doch
nicht immer weiter nach oben schreiben
geht immer dich dazu dämmen sondern dass
wir der Meinung sind dass wir umstellen
müssen von der alleinigen
Energieeffizienz hin zu der Frage der
Treibhausgasemissionen das befürwortet
zum Beispiel auch lowtech Ansätze die
dann preiswerter sind im Bauunterhalt
den Einsatz von nachhaltigen Materialien
und wenn sie dann zum Beispiel auch noch
ein Haus haben wo erneuerbare Energie
auf dem Dach Strom produziert dann haben
Sie natürlich auch die Möglichkeit
Nebenkosten zu sparen es gibt auch sehr
interessante Ansätze die jetzt im
Justizministerium entwickelt werden zur
teilbarmiete damit man beides zusammen
denkt und das große Potenzial unserer
Gebäude für die erneuerbaren Energien
auch abschöpft
vielen Dank dann habe ich eine Nachfrage
Jan Marco Luczak
Frau Ministerin sie haben gerade erwähnt
dass zum Anfang des kommenden Jahres der
Neubaustandard auf den Standard EA 55
ausgeweitet wird und das als
gesetzlicher Standard festgelegt wird
das war der Standard der in den
vergangenen Jahren mit sehr großen
Summen gefördert wurde um sozusagen
klimapolitisch auch ein Stück weit
voranzukommen das bedeutet also dass man
jetzt keine Förderung mehr hat die haben
sie gestrichen gleichzeitig wird der
Standard hochgesetzt und das führt in
der Folge auch dazu wir haben vorhin
schon über das eigentumskonzept
gesprochen dass sie sagen das was jetzt
gesetzlicher Standard ist ja 55 was
jetzt nicht mehr gefördert wird
das kann natürlich zukünftig nicht mehr
gefördert werden sondern wenn wir
Eigentumsförderung machen dann muss es
über den gesetzlichen Standard
hinausgehen also eher 40 plus das führt
aber dazu dass die Kosten die man dann
sozusagen hat wenn man diesen
förderfähigen Standard erreichen wir
natürlich enorm noch oben gehen
gleichzeitig sagen sie aber diejenigen
Haushalte die überhaupt in den Genuss
der Förderung kommen die dürfen maximal
60.000 € Haushaltseinkommen wie passt
das zusammen gleichzeitig die Kosten so
hoch zu treiben durch die Anforderung
aber gleichzeitig zu sagen da das
Haushaltseinkommen darf maximal 60.000
Euro leisten das klappt am Ende ja nicht
Frau Ministerin
Einkommens Höhen haben wir uns
orientiert an die durchschnittlichen
Einkommen die bei Baukindergeld beziehen
vorhanden waren die lagen sogar noch
unter den 60.000 die wir jetzt angesetzt
haben und das zweite Thema ist natürlich
dass die Nebenkosten ganz wesentlichen
Beitrag auch zu der Frage leisten kann
man sich das Gebäude auf die Dauer über
die Jahrzehnte leisten und jenseits
aller abstrakten Diskussion um
Förderfähigkeit oder nicht
Förderfähigkeit weiß ich dass jeder
private jetzt schon darüber nachdenkt
was er machen kann um sein Haus in
energetisch zu ertüchtigen um halt
Betriebskosten zu sparen die Kosten zu
sparen deswegen glaube ich dass alle
Menschen gut beraten sind die sich jetzt
ein Haus bauen dass sie sich einen sehr
energetisch effizientes Haus brauchen
eine Nachfrage das passt natürlich vom
Ministerin nicht mit dem zusammen was
die Verbände sagen also wurden und
Eigentum sagen zum Beispiel diese
Förderung verdient den Namen nicht weil
am Ende die Menschen die davon im
profitieren sollen mit diesem
Haushaltseinkommen diese sehr sehr
teuren Häuser mit dem Standard den sie
gesetzlich dann sozusagen vorsehen am
Ende dass ich nicht leisten können ganz
kurzer Punkt noch zum Baukindergeld
bitte mit der kurzen Anfahrt das
Baukindergeld haben sie gestrichen das
Programm Ende ist vorgezogen worden das
bedeutet das 15 bis 20.000 Familien
nicht mehr in den Genuss kommen werden
die da mit fest gerechnet haben in der
Finanzierung warum haben Sie das gemacht
wieso lassen Sie diese Familien im Regen
stehen
das war systematisch ein bisschen anders
das Baukindergeld hatte ja die
Eigenschaft dass man das Geld erst bekam
nachdem man eigentlich das Haus fertig
gebaut hatte und das war immer schon in
der Diskussion ob das wirklich die
sinnvolle Förderung ist oder ob es nicht
einfach sinnvoller ist den Familien am
Anfang zu helfen zum Beispiel auch
Eigenkapital nachzuweisen durch eine
staatliche Steuerung deswegen hat sich
dieser Bundestag entschieden eine andere
Form der Eigentumsförderung zu machen
die ist ab nächsten Jahr geben wird und
wir haben die programmschreiben von 23
vorgezogen damit wir dieses Jahr in
keine förderlücke laufen und deswegen
wird das überhaupt Kindergeld zum Ende
des Jahres auslaufen
und eine weitere Nachfrage ist Kollegen
beckamp
ja Frau Ministerin wir sprechen gerade
über die Bezahlbarkeit von Wohnraum über
die Höhe von mieten wer hätte gedacht
dass
steigende Wohnungsnachfrage durch
Masseneinwanderung zu deutlich höheren
Mieten führt hätten sie das gedacht Frau
Ministerin
also ich gebe gerne darüber dass diese
Bundesregierung Minister beantwortet
aber meine Gedanken sind meine Gedanken
und an der Stelle kann ich Ihnen sagen
dass wir dafür sorgen dass jeder der in
Deutschland lebt ein gutes Zuhause hat
egal wo seine Eltern herkommen
und die möglich
und die Möglichkeit der Nachfrage ja
vielen Dank Frau Ministerin das betonen
sie auf dass wir ein sehr attraktives
Land sind und deswegen ganz viele
Menschen zu uns kommen das freut sich
anscheinend sehr ich teile das nicht
ganz unbedingt für jeden wie schaut das
aus wenn wir dann eigentlich demnächst
wahrscheinlich 90 Millionen Menschen in
unserem Land haben wie unser Kanzler ist
schon dabei sind was machen wir denn
dann
frag doch ich empfehle da auch einfach
mal das Gespräch mit der Bauindustrie
die begrüßt zum Beispiel ganz
ausdrücklich was wir machen im Bereich
der Fachkräfte Einwanderung weil Hände
Regen der Menschen gesucht werden die
auf unseren Baustellen die Häuser bauen
wie sie einziehen können und alle
anderen Menschen
und die letzte Nachfrage ist der Kollege
füst
danke langes Öl
viel Erfolg alles gut
ich muss nochmal auf den Themenkomplex
energetischer Ernährung zurückkommen aus
dem wir jetzt gerade gekommen sind also
ich ignoriere jetzt mal den ganzen AFD
Mist in der Frage nochmal zu
energetische Sanierung wir haben ja
wir haben ja ja da da haben sie
allerdings recht die primitiv ihre
Position sind wir haben wir hatten ja
bei der Frage nach der Sanierung wie
können wir bezahlbaren Wohnraum schaffen
müssen wir auch feststellen wir haben in
den letzten
12 Jahren sehr viel Geld für den
energetische Ernährung investiert aber
der Gebäudebestand hängt hinterher was
die einspazierziele was sie einfach
Ziele
haben belangt jetzt wäre natürlich die
Frage ob wir nicht vielleicht doch mal
überlegen ob wir von der Dicke der
Dämmung von immer mehr Technik von der
alleinigen Fokussierung auf die
Energieeffizienz Weiterkommen auf das
was das Baby ist eher formuliert hat
nämlich emissionseffizienz was kommt da
raus und er wäre meine Meinung oder
meine Frage an Sie welchen Kostenvorteil
sehen Sie in diesem in diesem Konstrukt
aus meiner Sicht müssen wir genau das
machen um auch den Einsatz von
erneuerbaren und auch von
Recyclingmaterial und auch die
Wertschätzung des Bestandes zu schaffen
weil wenn man nur darauf fokussiert zu
sagen wird wie viel Energie verbraucht
das Haus wenn man wenn es da steht dann
ignoriert man natürlich die Frage wie
viel Energie habe ich eigentlich
gebraucht um das Dämmmaterial
herzustellen und dann kommt man nicht zu
einem realen belastungsbild und deswegen
haben wir dieses Qualitätssiegel
nachhaltiges Gebäude entwickelt und das
werden wir auch mit Ihnen diskutieren
wie in Zukunft zum Beispiel diese
Annäherung an ihrer 40 dann
interpretiert und ausgestaltet wird
damit man tatsächlich auch das Ziel hat
dass man sich ehrlich macht im Bereich
und dass man ein Gesamtbild hat was dann
tatsächlich sämtliche Emission spiegeln
die in diesem Bereich da sind die
digitale Gebäude Ressourcen passt wird
da wichtig sein aber auch natürlich Böhm
damit wir besser als bisher wissen was
steckt dann eigentlich an Potenzial in
dem Gebäude und wir können aber das
besser nutzen und natürlich werden wir
auch bei der
sanierungswelle die wir ja haben werden
schauen inwiefern zum Beispiel durch
erneuerbarer Energie es schaffen dass
wir nicht jeden Gebäudebestand tiefen
sanieren das wird auch nicht möglich
sein
und vielen Dank für Ihre ganz kurze
Nachfrage also wenn wir jetzt den Fokus
wegnehmen von der alleinigen
gebäudeenergie das höre ich sehr gerne
wir fokussieren uns bei allen Maßnahmen
aber auch immer nur auf das alleinige
Gebäude ähnlich wie man sagt mehr
Emission Effizienz statt
energieeffizienz ist auch der Blick eher
auf das Quartier immer wieder im Fokus
der Debatte wie stehen Sie dazu müssen
wir erst Quartier anschauen und etwas
weiter wegkommen vom Gebäude oder passt
das alles so wie wir es machen
das Bauministerium hat ja eine
jahrzehntelange Tradition in der
Städtebauförderung genau das zu tun
nämlich im Quartier zu denken und wir
werden das auch machen müssen bei der
kommunalen wärmeplanung aber auch bei
der Anpassung der Städte insgesamt an
den Klimawandel hatte ich ja vorhin
ausgeführt man springt zu kurz wenn man
nur das eigentliche Gebäude betrachtet
wir werden auch Gebäude haben die kann
man gar nicht in der effizient in dem
Sinne machen weil sie unter
Denkmalschutz stehen oder andere
Probleme mit sich bringen oder weil sie
vielleicht gar nicht mehr dauerhaft
gehalten werden sollen das kann man dann
kompensieren indem man einen anderen
höheren Standard an anderen Bereichen in
demselben Quartier hat und das wird ganz
ganz wichtig sein bei der Ausgestaltung
der kommunalen wärmeplanung
vielen Dank die nächste reguläre
Fragestellerin ist für die Linke Susanne
henningwellso
Präsidentin Frau Ministerin das
Bundesverwaltungsgericht hat im November
2021 das Verkaufsrecht in Milieu
Schutzgebieten gekippt das bedeutet dass
mindestens die zehn großen Städte in ihr
eines der wenigen Instrumente verloren
haben um gegen Spekulationen vorzugehen
luxusanieren Mieterhöhungen verhindern
zu können auch für die Mieterinnen und
Mieter und jetzt sogenannte
abwendungsvereinbarung sogar beklagt
werden tausende Wohnungen sind
mittlerweile verkauft sie haben damals
gesagt die Bundesregierung wird sich
kümmern dann ist natürlich meine Frage
wann wird die Bundesregierung mit einem
neuen Vorschlag Niefern
ja mein Ministerium hat im April einen
entsprechenden Gesetzesentwurf in die
Ressortabstimmung gegeben es gibt
erheblichen nachfragebedarf seitens des
Justizministeriums insbesondere wann wir
da zu einer Einigung kommen kann ich
nicht abschätzen aber wenn ich mir vor
Weihnachten etwas wünschen darf dann
würde ich mich sehr freuen wenn wir das
sehr sehr schnell hinkriegen
sie haben die Möglichkeit danach Frage
vielen Dank Frau Ministerin also dieser
Wunsch der eint uns ja dann ahnt ja auch
zum Beispiel viele Bürgermeisterinnen
und Bürgermeister der 10 betroffenen
Städte da runter auch sehr viele SPD
regiert nun habe ich das aber so
verstanden dass sie bei diesem
Gesetzentwurf federführend sind und ich
kann jetzt noch ein gewisser Hinsicht
verstehen dass bei Mietrecht man sagt
die FDP und der FDP Minister Sitze aus
aber beim Vorkaufsrecht haben sie die
Federführung und deswegen haben auch sie
die Verantwortung aus meiner Sicht das
schnellstmöglich umzusetzen es geht um
zwei Paragraphen die geändert werden
müssen deswegen meine Frage wann werden
sie angesetzt und vorlegen
ja wenn die ressort-stimmung zu Ende ist
dann werden wir es dem Kabinett zuleiten
vielen Dank Frau Bayram
vielen Dank Frau Präsidentin Frau
Ministerin es gibt ja einen
Referentenentwurf der sage ich mal in
interessierten Kreisen auch schon
grassiert und da sind sehr viele
vernünftige Ansätze drin und insoweit
würde mich eben tatsächlich
interessieren auch mit Blick darauf dass
in meinem Wahlkreis in Friedrichshain
Kreuzberg und in der Stadt Berlin
tatsächlich viele Mieterinnen und Mieter
einfach dieses Vorkaufsrecht brauchen um
vor Verdrängung geschützt zu werden und
um in ihren Wohnungen verbleiben zu
können wie sie denn die Situation
einschätzen wie sozusagen die Kommunen
tatsächlich wieder in den Stand versetzt
werden Vorkaufsrecht auszuüben oder sind
Sie der Ansicht dass die das zurzeit
tatsächlich können weil das ist ja auch
immer wieder etwas was wir im Ausschuss
diskutieren
nein wir sind da ein gesetzlichen
Regelungsbedarf ich weiß jetzt nicht
vorher sie den Referentenentwurf haben
aber das ist ihm gibt es ja Ausdruck der
Tatsache dass wir da einen Bedarf sehen
und die Möglichkeit einer Nachfrage ja
vielen Dank es ist natürlich ein Entwurf
der in interessierten Kreisen diskutiert
wird der eben noch nicht Ressort
abgestimmt wird also da hat die Frau
Leier etwas in den Raum gestellt wo man
eben auch sagen können
Ressortabstimmungen heiser führende
Ministerium liegt was vor und ein mit
Zeichen des Ministerium zeichnet nicht
mit und dann stehen wir hier alle hier
mit unseren frommen Weihnachtswünschen
und ja ich gebe zu für meine Fraktion
Bündnis 90 die Grünen wir wünschen uns
dieses Jahr zu Weihnachten auch bitte
das Vorkaufsrecht damit wir endlich die
MieterInnen schützen können deswegen wie
können wir Sie dabei unterstützen
ja ich spreche hier für die
Bundesregierung die Bundesregierung an
sich ist noch dabei sich dazu zu
positionieren insofern ist meine
Position als fachministerin klar und
schwer sicherlich hilfreich wenn Sie mit
anderen Mitgliedern der Bundesregierung
einen gleiches Gespräch führen
und ich habe eine Nachfrage des Kollegen
Rover
nein frau Präsidentin Frau Ministerin
ich möchte genau dazu noch mal
nachfragen sie
haben ausgeführt dass sie da in der
Resort Abstimmung sind aber wir haben ja
eine Ungleichgewicht zwischen Stadt und
dem ländlichen Raum in den ländlichen
Räumen haben wir zunehmend Leerstand und
hier sollen wir sozusagen die Kommunen
in die Situation bringen dass sie
Eigentum sich aneignen können deswegen
meine Frage an Sie was sehen Sie denn
noch für Möglichkeiten damit wir
Kommunen unterstützen können in diesen
Gebieten zu unterstützen im Bereich der
Sanierung usw
was auf jeden Fall immer geht und ja
auch praktiziert wird ist dass man über
die städteförderung Mittel hat um in
einzelnen Bereichen steht im mauerlichen
Missstand zu bekämpfen dass andere ist
eine Sanierungsförderung die natürlich
auch im ländlichen Raum genutzt werden
kann wir unterstützen jetzt gerade auch
die Entwicklung von Alternativen
Mobilitätskonzepten im ländlichen Raum
über das bwsr und unser Wunsch ist dass
wir nächstes Jahr auch eine
kleinstadtakademie etablieren können wo
wir gerade für die ganze zentralen
kleinen Städte die ein Anker sind im
ländlichen Raum auch mehr
Austauschmöglichkeiten haben und unsere
Modellprojekte zum Beispiel Innenstadt
das ist auch möglich in kleineren
Städten genutzt zu werden um Ortslagen
zu reaktivieren und ich kann Ihnen
versichern als Brandenburgerin ist mir
der ländliche Raum sehr nahe deswegen
haben wir jetzt auch ähm
Formulierungshilfe zu Änderungen des
Baugesetzbuches zum Umbau von Stellen
zugeliefert weil das ganz wesentlich ist
auch für Investitionssicherheit im
ländlichen Raum
und eine Nachfrage
sanieren im Bestand zurück auch wenn sie
sagen das macht das Haus des Kollegen
Harbeck trotzdem an Sie die Frage zu
Ihrem Ressort gehört die Bundesstiftung
Baukultur die hat zum Sanieren im
Bestand sich gerade mit einer
umfangreichen Äußerung bewegt was machen
Sie jetzt damit sagen sie das macht ihr
zu Kollege Harbeck oder sind sie da
tätig und nehmen einzelne Punkte ganz
konkret mit ihrem Haus raus damit man
sozusagen kostengünstiger sanieren kann
im Bestand
jeden Fall das ist ein ganz wichtiger
Punkt ich hatte gesagt wir müssen die
Honorarordnungen der Architekten
überarbeiten damit es sich für Sie auch
lohnt Umbau zu planen und nicht dass sie
mehr verdienen wenn Sie neubauplan das
andere ist dass wir uns anschauen müssen
im Bereich der baugesetzbuchnovelle ob
wir zum Beispiel gerade im ländlichen
Bereich noch
Änderungsbedarf haben im Bereich des
Baugesetzbuches um zum Beispiel
ehemalige nicht mehr genutzte Stelle
umzubauen zu wohnen geworden ob es da
noch anderen Regelungsbedarf gibt als
bisher aber auch der Umbau der Stelle
selber ist ein wichtiges Thema und wir
müssen über die Standards reden weil
wenn man umbaut und es dann sozusagen
ein altes Gebäude die Standards von 2023
erfüllen soll das wird nicht gehen
deswegen ist das ein ganz großes Paket
was wir da angehen müssen
ich habe noch zwei nachfragen die ich
zulasse einmal der Kollege Nicoles bitte
ja sehr geehrte Frau Ministerin erstmal
vielen Dank dass Sie hier so engagiert
und klar die Fragen beantworten wir
befassen uns ja gerade damit wie wir
Kommunen Stärken bei dem
Herausforderungen beim Thema Wohnen und
deswegen ist es wichtig auch noch mal
eine Nachfrage aus meiner Sicht zum
Thema Wohnungslosigkeit ein sehr breit
aufgestelltes für Nomen wo die Kommune
kommunale Ebene deutlich Unterstützung
auch durch den Bund erfahren muss und wo
wir als Ampel Koalition ja auch ein
klares Ziel gesetzt haben mit den
nationalen Aktionsplan bis 2030 im
Wohnungslosigkeit zu überwinden da haben
wir jetzt auch die erste bundesweite
Statistik zum Thema Wohnungslosigkeit
und für mich wäre jetzt erstmal
interessant wie der aktuelle Stand zum
Nationalen Aktionsplan Wohnungslosigkeit
ist und was das Ministerium da aktuell
an Planung hat fürs nächste Jahr fragt
Nicoles für die SPD-Fraktion
also wir werden nächstes Jahr anfangen
mit den Akteuren mit denen wir jetzt
schon in den ersten Austausch getreten
sind diesen Aktionsplan vorzubereiten
hier ist ganz wichtig zum einen die
kommunale Ebene die ja seit Jahrzehnten
an diesem Thema arbeitet mitzunehmen
aber auch die Ressorts wir haben große
Probleme was die Krankenversicherung von
Obdachlosen anbelangt aber wir haben
manchmal auch das Problem dass ein
Melderecht noch Lücken gibt das kann
selbst der engagierteste Sozialarbeiter
nicht ohne Änderung des Bundes
bearbeiten und deswegen wird es darauf
ankommen sowohl die kommunale Ebene mit
einzubeziehen die Akteure aber natürlich
auch die Selbstvertretung der Menschen
die von Obdachlosigkeit betroffen sind
mit ins Boot zu nehmen wir werden
regionale Veranstaltungen machen wir
werden ins Land gehen aber ich werde
auch mir Länder anschauen wie Finnland
zum Beispiel im Februar die es geschafft
haben die Zahl der Obdachlosen zu
reduzieren durch hausigen first Ansätze
und wir werden auch mit Architekten
darüber sprechen wie gute Architektur
aussieht für Menschen die jemals
obdachlos waren wir haben über die 14
Milliarden für den sozialen Wohnungsbau
auch Geld um entsprechende Wohnung zu
errichten also es wird nicht eine
Maßnahme es wird ein ganzer Plan sein
und unser Ziel ist es nächstes Jahr
diesen Plan zu erstellen
es wäre schön wenn wir die Nachfragen
wirklich auf den Punkt beziehen denen
die Ministerin am Anfang gesagt hat weil
wir sind jetzt in die Wohnungslosigkeit
gekommen das wäre wahrscheinlich ihre
reguläre Frage gewesen die sie gehabt
hätten wenn sie dran gewesen wären als
regulärer Fragestellung aber jetzt noch
mal eine Nachfrage stellen am besten
zu dem Bereich von Weg gut ich war etwas
irritiert dass das erste Mal für mich
und ich fand insgesamt war der Rahmen
sehr weit gewählt bei allen Nachfragen
deswegen danke dass Sie mir das auch
erlauben und dieses wichtige Thema auch
zu der kommunalen Stärkung die Kommunen
darzustärken dieses Thema anzugehen beim
Thema Wohnen für mich wären vielleicht
noch mal die Nachfrage welche Schlüssel
und Handlungsaufträge lassen sich aus
dem Wohnungslosen Bericht 2022
ziehen der ja auch sehr wesentlich
sicherlich ist als Arbeitsgrundlage für
den nationalen Aktionsplan herzlichen
Dank
die Zuständigkeit der Wohnungslosen
Berichterstattung wechselt ja zum ersten
ersten 23 vom BMAS zu uns wir werden das
Weiterführen weil das ein ganz wichtige
Grundlage ist dafür dass wir die
richtigen Antworten geben weil die
wohnungs- und Obdachlosigkeit
unterscheidet sich zwischen den Menschen
die tatsächlich auf der Straße leben
denen die in Unterbringung leben und
denen die versteckt obdachlos sind viele
darunter Frauen die schwierigen
Situationen feststecken weil sie keinen
eigenen Wohnraum haben das sind sehr
unterschiedlich Zusammensetzungen dieser
Zielgruppen dieser Gruppen von Menschen
die von wohnungssuchlichkeit betroffen
sind
und die nächste Frage kommt aus der
Unionsfraktion Petra Nicola funktioniert
ja funktioniert ja vielen Dank von der
Wohnungslosigkeit jetzt einmal noch mal
zur wohngeldreform Frau Ministerin sie
sind auch kommunalministerin und an der
Stelle haben die Kommunen die Gesetze
dann auch entsprechend umzusetzen ich
frage mich nehmen Sie die Kommunen ernst
nehmen Sie die Hinweise ernst oder warum
ist es bei der Umsetzung des Wohngeldes
zu desolaten Situationen gekommen bzw
warum wurden die Hinweise der Kommunen
einfach
ignoriert
also ich will noch mal darauf hinweisen
Frau Minister wir können gleich
antworten aber das ist jetzt wieder ein
ganz neuer Themenbereich es ging um
Nachfragen zu dem Bereich davor darum
möchte ich gerne genau es ging ums
Vorkaufsrecht vorweg und ich bitte dass
wir unsere beschlossene Regelung auch
einhalten sonst
implodiert irgendwie das
fragestellungssystem darum
[Musik]
lasse ich jetzt diese eine Frage zu und
keine Nachfrage und gehe dann weiter
noch mal eine Nachfrage zum
Vorkaufsrecht und dann in die nächste
Runde wir haben noch sieben Minuten
auch Mieter die in Häusern mit
kommunalen Vorkaufsrecht wurden bekommen
ja Wohngeld insofern
darf ich Ihnen versichern ich war 15
Jahre statt vorne ich habe den
kommunalen wohnungsausschuss in Potsdam
geleitet und die Abteilungsleiterin die
jetzt diese wohngeldreform macht die war
am letzten Jahr noch Bürgermeisterin
einer kleinen Stadt in Brandenburg wir
sind im intensiven Austausch mit der
kommunalen Ebene wissen was das eine
riesen Herausforderung ist und wir
machen das nicht aus Jux und Tollerei so
zügig sondern weil die Leute einfach
diese Unterstützung brauchen wir haben
ein parlamentarischen Verfahren viele
Vereinfachungen auch aufgenommen die
Verlängerung des Bewilligungszeitraums
auf zwei Jahre die Bagatellgrenze die
Möglichkeit der Beschreibung der
vorläufigen Bescheidung das sind
wichtige Punkte wir unterstützen auch
gerne bei der Digitalisierung aber im
parlamentarischen Verfahren haben sie ja
Hinweise diskutiert einige angenommen
andere nicht und der große Brocken
nämlich die Verschlankung der
Verwaltungsvereinbarung die wir geerbt
haben mit über 150 Seiten das wird auch
unsere Arbeit im nächsten Jahr prägen so
dass wir auch untergesetzlich noch
weitere Anregungen und Vereinfachung
aufnehmen werden können
vielen Dank und die nächste
Fragestellung aus Karin live
und ich würde auch tatsächlich sehr
gerne noch mal zur Ursprungsfrage
zurückkommen zum Vorkaufsrecht und ich
glaube geschätzte Frau Kollegin sie und
ich viele hier wissen dass es eigentlich
eine einzige Hängepartie ist und das ist
peinlich ist darüber einem Jahr kein
Gesetz zu ändern wo es nur zwei
Paragraphen Bedarfen würde und ich frage
auch gerne ihren Kollegen Herrn
Buschmann warum er sich stark verstellt
aber heute stehen sie Rede und Antwort
und sie sind federführend SPD und Grüne
haben zusammen die Mehrheit in der
Koalition deswegen ist meine Frage wie
kann es sein dass der kleinste
Koalitionspartner in diesem Themengebiet
offenbar bestimmt wie kann es sein dass
sie sich da nicht durchsetzen können
dass sich der SPD nicht durchsetzen kann
und das auch der Kanzler für bezahlbares
Wohnen an dieser Stelle nicht wie auch
in vielen anderen Stellen keinen
Machtwort spricht um das kommunale
Vorkaufsrecht im Interesse der
Mieterinnen und Mieter und im Interesse
der Kommunen wieder herzustellen
also sie werden ja bemerkt haben wie
viele Gesetze in diesem ersten Jahr aus
dem Bauministerium gekommen sind die
ganzen Gesetze Heizkostenzuschuss
wohngeldreform mehrfache Novelle des
Baugesetzbuches das sind alles
abwägungsprozesse und ich würde mich
auch nicht unter Druck setzen lassen
wenn ich als bauministerin noch
nachfragebedarf inhaltlicher Art zu
einem Gesetzesentwurf eines Kollegen
habe dann stelle ich das bis alle Fragen
beantwortet sind dass Justizministerium
hat noch mehrere Fragen zu diesem
Prozess das ist ja auch die Frage in wie
vielen Kommunen wie oft das angewandt
wird um abzuschätzen zu können für das
Justizministerium sehr wichtig wie hoch
da tatsächlich der gesetzliche
Regelungsbedarf ist und deswegen ist das
nicht nur die Frage ob man mal zwei
Sätze in einem Gesetz ändert sondern das
sind ja auch komplexe juristische
Fragestellungen Einschätzung und
insofern braucht es seine Zeit ich habe
gesagt ich würde mich freuen wenn diese
Zeit dann bald zu Ende ist und wir uns
auf eingesetztes Entwurf verständigen
können aber ansonsten ist das kollegiale
Miteinander in der Bundesregierung
dadurch geprägt dass man sich nicht
gegen gegenseitig mit dem Fuß
aufstampend unter Druck setzt sondern
dass man so lange miteinander diskutiert
bis man ein ordentlichen Konsens
gefunden hat
sie haben keine Nachfrage Frau Leim
vielen Dank dann komme ich zum nächsten
regulären Fragesteller das ist Hagen
Reinhold
Hagen Reinhold ist Mitglied der
FDP-Fraktion
Frau Ministerin die steigenden Baukosten
halten uns alle in Atem auch die
Verfügbarkeit von Material auch die
materialpreissteigerungen und wir haben
ja ein gesellschaftlich und politischen
Willen auch mehr Recyclingmaterial mehr
bereits hergestelltes Material zu
verwenden
nicht nur weil wir das abgebrochene
Material kommen deponieren können wir
kaum Kapazitäten da sind weil es eben
auch sinnvoll ist Kreislaufwirtschaft zu
betreiben jetzt ist die
Ersatzbaustoffverordnung gerade in der
Novellierung wie ist ihr Haus damit
eingebunden wird es die Möglichkeit
geben Abbruch Material zu klassifizieren
damit wir mehr sekundär Baustoff zu
primärbaustoff werden lassen und damit
viel ökologischer Zukunft bauen können
als das jetzt der Fall ist
wir sind eingebunden und wir wollen
unseren Beitrag dazu leisten dass
verstanden wird dass Abfall nicht Abfall
ist sondern der Rohstoff von morgen
und ich habe die Möglichkeit dazu
Nachfrage
danke für diese knackige und knappe
Antwort trotzdem wäre mir lieb zu
erfahren ab wann ich das Abbruchmaterial
nicht mehr unter die Straße oder in die
Deponie fahre sondern verwenden kann um
es wieder zu verwenden beim Bau das hat
die konkrete Frage wann sind sie
zeitlich durch und dann schließlich an
was macht ihr Ministerium auch noch
heimische und regionale Baustoffe z.B
die Erschließung von gipsgruppen in
Deutschland voranzutreiben da brauchen
wir auch nach dem auslaufenden Reha gibt
es zügig eine Veränderung
ja beim Bereich der Schließung von neuen
vorkommen ist es sicherlich sinnvoll
dass sie sich noch mal anschauen was wir
gemacht haben mit der Novelle des
raumordnungsgesetzes da wurde ein Jahr
wesentliche Vereinfachung auch geschafft
was insbesondere die
raumverträglichkeitsprüfung von großen
Vorhaben anbelangtes anderes in der Tat
die Frage der Akzeptanz vor Ort wenn das
im Planungsrecht überführt werden muss
und ich weiß dass die gibt es Industrie
in Deutschland an Alternativen zum
entrauchungs- und die auch vorhanden
sind die sogar interessanterweise auch
im Bereich des Recyclings von jetzt
vorhandenen Abfällen zu suchen ist und
ansonsten die andere Frage wann sie das
machen können die Regulierungen in
diesem Bereich ist ein bisschen in
Abhängigkeit auch der Vorgaben der EU
und ich bin ganz optimistisch dass wir
das im Laufe des nächsten Jahres
bekommen
und ich habe eine Nachfrage des Kollegen
Kiesling
jede Frau Ministerin eine Frage hätte
ich noch zum steigenden Baukosten wir
haben das Thema der mantelverordnung
wann wird denn die abfalleigenschaft
wegfallen dass wir wieder
recyclingbaustoffe vielleicht hat
einsetzen können und das zweite Thema
ist steigende Baukosten was gedenken Sie
zu tun wir merken ja dass Baugenehmigung
zurückgehen das Zinsen steigen das
teilweise Bauplätze zurückgegeben
Kredite nicht bedient werden können und
nicht mehr ausgegeben werden können und
wie schaffen wir diese Baukosten so in
den Griff zu bekommen das wieder gebaut
wird sie haben gesagt sie wollen die
baukapazitäten ausbauen das haben sie
hier gesagt hatten heute früh im
Ausschuss auch gesagt wie wollen Sie das
leisten
also die erste Frage im nächsten Jahr
hoffe ich dass das der Fall sein wird
und das andere dass es sehr komplex ich
würde erstmal sagen wenn wir Baukosten
dämpfen arbeiten können ist das schon
viel das eine ist natürlich die 200
Milliarden Entlastung die Gas und
strompreisbremse das ist natürlich auch
ein Beitrag für die
Baustoffindustrie damit die überhaupt
wieder planen kann das andere ist dass
ich mit Jim Özdemir dabei bin auch eine
Holzbau Initiative vorzubereiten weil
natürlich Holsten ganz spannender
nachwachsener Rohstoff ist und das
andere ist der Einsatz von
Recyclingmaterial kann hoffentlich auch
dazu führen dass man andere Preise hat
als beim Einsatz von primärer Rohstoffen
und kombiniert werden muss das natürlich
mit absolut der Verkürzung von
Planungsverfahren das ist ja das Ziel
der Regierung dass wir die
Planungsprozesse in Deutschland deutlich
verkürzen weil jeder Monat Planung ist
natürlich einen Monat mit potenziellen
Baukosten Steigung und dann sind wir
dabei unterschiedliche Maßnahmen zu
ergreifen um die planprozesse zu aber
natürlich auch durch Digitalisierung es
insgesamt schneller und einfacher zu
machen
eine Nachfrage bitte vielen Dank ja zum
Thema Baukosten zum Thema Baukosten
gehören ja auch die Planungskosten jetzt
haben Sie gesagt Sie wollen die Hauer i
ändern dass man im Bereich des planen
bestaunt vielleicht eine Leistungsphase
einführen kann wir rechnen sie dort mit
die Baukosten steigern was bedeutet es
mehr an Kosten für den Bauherren bzw
dann später an den Mieter es muss ja
umgelegt werden und das andere Team ist
das Qualitätssiegel nachhaltiges Gebäude
ressourcenbach das sind zusätzlich
administrative Aufgaben
wer zahlt das letztendlich wird der
Förderung geben weil wenn wir gesehen in
der letzten legislaturper sagt jetzt
hier das werden
aufgebaut haben 100.000 Arbeitsplätze im
Baubereich jetzt sehen wir dass es
zurückgeht was sagen Sie mit diesen
administrativen Aufgaben die jetzt noch
mal anstoßen werden
heute zeigen dass wir sogar ein
beschäftigungsaufwuchs haben im
Baubereich und die Anzahl der Bauanträge
entwickelt sich auch sehr
unterschiedlich wir haben auch einen
kleinen aufwuchs sogar im Bereich der
Mehrfamilienhäuser des wissen sie
insgesamt kann ich jetzt noch nicht
Herrschaft sagen was die Endung der
Hauerei pro Wohneinheit dann mit sich
bringen wird aber wenn wir den Umbau
fördern dann ist natürlich auch klar das
ist ja im Vergleich zum kompletten
Neubau einer sehr sparsame Sache das
heißt wenn sie aus einem bestehenden
Bürogebäude dann eine Wohnung bauen dann
dürfte die im Durchschnitt wesentlich
preiswerter sein als wenn sie die
Wohnung komplett neu machen
vielen Dank da wir noch einige
Nachfragen und auch noch keine noch
nicht mal eine reguläre Runde durch sind
würde ich die
Befragung um 15 Minuten verlängern und
die nächste ist die Melanie wegling für
ihre reguläre Frage
vielen Dank Frau Präsidentin
sehr geehrte Frau Ministerin als
bauministerin setzen sich besonders für
den sozialen Wohnungsbau ein und sie
legen dabei auch einen wichtigen
Schwerpunkt auf den Bereich junges
wohnen wir haben es heute auch schon
gehört in den Jahren 2022 bis 2026 sind
insgesamt 14,5 Milliarden Euro für den
sozialen Wohnungsbau vorgesehen und
allein im Programm Jahr 2023 standen sie
daraus das junge Wohnen mit 500
Millionen Euro aus das ist also wichtig
für viele Studierende aber auch für
viele Auszubildende meine Frage an der
Stelle wie sind denn die nächsten
Schritte für die Förderung des jungen
Wohnens aus ihrer Sicht fragt Melanie
wegling aus der SPD wir verhandeln
gerade herzlichen Dank für die Frage die
Verwaltungsvorschrift junges Wohnen mit
den Ländern die muss noch dieses Jahr
aus meiner Sicht rausgehen können oder
so weit sind wir in den Verhandlungen
und sie tritt dann in Kraft wenn alle 16
Bundesländer das unterzeichnet und
zurückgeschickt haben das dauert immer
ein paar Wochen und dann sind die Länder
in der Lage das Geld auszugeben sie
können dann eigene Förderprogramme
machen weil die Situation sehr
unterschiedlich sind einige werden
sicherlich einen Schwerpunkt setzen auch
auf Sanierung andere auf zum Beispiel
auch die Neubau von Auszubildenden
Wohnheimen und Studentenwohnheimen oder
der ein oder andere wird vielleicht auch
Belegungsrechte erwerben die Frage die
Höhe der Förderkonditionen die ist dann
in der Verantwortung der Länder und wir
sind da aber auch sehr offen dass wir
andere Förderkonditionen haben als im
klassischen sozialen Wohnungsbau weil
die wohnungszuschnitte und die
Bedürfnisse sich natürlich auch
unterscheiden zwischen Studierenden
Azubis und dem normalen wohnen in einem
Haus und sie haben die Möglichkeit eine
Nachfrage ja mich würde noch mal
detailliert interessieren welche
Rahmenbedingungen aus ihrer Sicht
geschaffen werden müssen
unter Umständen auf Bundesebene auf
Landesebene welche Rahmenbedingungen
brauchen wir um das Gute bezahlbare
Wohnen für junge Menschen für
Studierende und für Auszubildende weiter
zu fördern und unterstützen
bei den Studierenden ist es ein bisschen
einfacher weil wir da ja die etablierte
Struktur haben über die Studentenwerke
als Träger bei den Wohnheimen für
Auszubildende muss man neben der Frage
wo kommt das Geld für den Bau her das
haben wir jetzt geklärt auch nach
schauen wo zum Beispiel
Betreuungspersonal bezahlt werden kann
weil auszubildende sind ja in der Regel
unter 18 wenn sie anfangen das heißt
wenn man azubi-bewohner im hat muss man
auch die Frage beantworten der
Trägerschaft das ist ja nicht geklärt
wie bei den Studentenwerken und B
natürlich auch die Frage wie kann eine
Finanzierung Aussehen von dem
Betreuungspersonal aber ich werbe noch
mal ganz ausdrücklich auch dafür Azubi
Wohnheime zu bauen wir brauchen dringend
die Stärkung der
duales heute sehr schwer auf unserem
Wohnungsmarkt
vielen Dank dann hätte der Jan
markolucczak eine Nachfrage
es ging gerade um das Thema junges
Wohnen gerade viele junge Menschen
haben Schwierigkeiten ihre Mieten zu
bezahlen deswegen werden sie unter
anderem auch durch das Wohngeld
unterstützt sie haben jetzt nun auch
heute schon gesagt dass die größte
wohngeldreform in den letzten
Jahrzehnten die auf den Weg gebracht
worden ist soll alles zum 1 Januar in
Kraft treten die Menschen warten auch
auf ihr Geld brauchen das auch wirklich
dringend nun hören wir aber aus den
Kommunen das ist vorhin gerade auch
schon angesprochen worden ein Hilferuf
nach dem anderen Personal fehlt die IT
ist nicht fertig wir lesen das in der
Zeitung das in den Ämtern dort total das
Wohngeld Chaos droht und deswegen haben
wir jetzt hier im Bundestag ja auch
gesagt die Berechnungsverfahren müssen
deutlich vereinfacht werden damit das
fehlende Personal was man eben nicht so
schnell aufbauen kann entlastet wird
davon ist allerdings im
parlamentarischen Verfahren nichts übrig
geblieben sondern ganz im Gegenteil
durch vorläufige Prüfung etc die am Ende
dazu führen dass man einen
Verwaltungsprogramm möglicherweise sogar
zweimal anfangen muss wird sozusagen das
noch verdoppelt und deswegen noch mal
die Frage was wollen Sie denn tun wenn
wir am Anfang Januar feststehen das
Wohngeld wird nicht bei den Menschen
ankommen sondern wird sich bis zur Mitte
des Jahres oder darüber hinaus hinziehen
ich hatte ihn ja im Ausschuss gesagt die
Bild-Zeitung hatte da gestern eine
kleine Fehlmeldung was auch die ITU
Software anbelangt wir haben Übersicht
das alle Bundesländer ist im ersten
Quartal und die allermeisten
Bundesländer ist im Januar schaffen das
neue Wohngeld dann auszuzahlen und das
zweite das ist das vorläufige Verfahren
ist ein ganz einfaches Verfahren und man
wenige Nachweise Einkommen und Miethöhen
bringen muss und es ist nicht richtig
dass es dann ein zweites mal angefasst
werden muss sondern der vorläufige
Wohngeldbescheid wird nach Zeitablauf zu
einem endgültigen so dass genau das was
sie befürchten nämlich die doppelte
Arbeit nicht vorhanden ist und wir haben
verlängert den Bewilligungszeitraum von
12 auf 24 Monate eine ganze wesentliche
Unterstützung damit man dann auch genug
Zeit hat für die neuen Antragsteller und
wir werden auch im Rahmen der die Dialog
ist mit den Kommunen und den Ländern
auch die Verwaltungsvorschriften
opulentes Werk deutlich verschlanken im
nächsten Jahr so dass wir auch
untergesetzlich noch weitere vereinfach
machen werden und die Möglichkeit eine
Nachfrage sehr gern ich muss wieder
korrigieren Frau Ministerin sie haben ja
gesagt dass die vorläufige Prüfung
automatisch zu einer endgültigen wird
das ist nicht so nach dem Gesetz sondern
es kann so sein wenn nicht bestimmte
Umstände eintreten das führt aber dazu
dass die Menschen die jetzt Wohngeld
bekommen und durch die Verlängerung des
Bewilligungszeitraum über viele Monate
auch bekommen immer in der gefahren sind
dieses Geld zu großen Anteilen auch
wieder zurückzahlen müssen weil das eben
nur vorläufig ist noch nicht endgültig
sie haben vorhin von der Bagatellgrenze
gesprochen die beträgt 50 €, das ist
nichts und deswegen meine Frage wenn wir
so eine geringe Bagatellgrenzen haben
die Menschen in der gefahren sind das
zurückzahlen müssen wie wollen Sie dann
mit diesen absehbaren schwierigen
sozialen Konstellationen dann umgehen
dass die Menschen Geld zurückzahlen
müssen was sie gar nicht haben
Fall würde der kluge Staat sicherlich
eine Lösung finden aber es ist immer
noch besser ich bekomme etwas aufgrund
einer vorläufigen eines vorläufigen
Bescheids als dass ich Monate warte und
es nicht bekomme
und sie können sich gerne auch noch mal
wir können Ihnen das zur Verfügung
stellen den Anteil derjenigen
Rückforderungen angucken die bis 50 €
sind es nachheblicher Anteil wir haben
im parlamentarische Verfahren gesagt wir
evaluieren das aber natürlich darf man
auch keine viel Anreize setzen deswegen
die 50% erhebliche Entlastung auch der
rückforderungszahlen sollte es sich
erweisen dass eine andere Grenze
sinnvoller ist können wir uns das gerne
in zwei Jahren anschauen aber jetzt ist
es ein ganz großer Beitrag auch das
Verfahren von Anfang an ähm einfacher zu
machen aber wir haben dann noch viel vor
bei der einfacheren Bearbeitung des
Wohngeldes da ist in den letzten Jahren
leider zu wenig passiert
und eine Nachfrage von der Nicoles
ja ich habe ja gerade gelernt muss ich
zu der eigentlichen Frage beziehen das
Wohngeld ob das jetzt dazugehört weiß
ich an der Stelle auch nicht vor allem
weil bafög-empfänger:innen ja nicht
wohngeldberechtigt sind sondern übers
Bafög eben abgedeckt sind für mich wäre
noch mal wichtig vielleicht welche
Chancen und Perspektiven beim jungen
wohnen auch in unterschiedlichen
wurmformen liegt und welche
Beteiligungsmöglichkeiten vielleicht
auch von jungen Menschen gesehen werden
genau in diesem Kontext vielleicht auch
gerade die Herausforderung bei den Azubi
wohnen wie vielleicht auch noch mal jung
und ausbildungsvertretung eingebunden
werden können in solchen Prozessen und
Betriebe ob es da vielleicht auch
Ansätze und die Ideen gibt da wird mich
einfach normal ihre Haltung zu
interessieren Frau Ministerin danke
schön
ja wir hatten zur Konzeption dieses
Programmes in Dialog mit Vertretern von
Organisationen die entsprechend in dem
Bereich unterwegs sind vom Studentenwerk
aber natürlich auch von Vertretern der
Gewerkschaften und der Handwerkskammern
und wir werden diesen Dialog im nächsten
Jahr noch mal suchen und informieren das
ist jetzt dieses Programm gibt und wir
natürlich alles dafür tun dass es auch
möglichst schnell angenommen wird das
heißt wir werden als Ministerium auf
Bundesebene mit den Verbänden
informieren dass es diese Möglichkeiten
gibt und ich weiß das auch in den
einzelnen Ländern schon Vorbereitung
laufen gerade die Studentenwerke sind
schon in der Vorplanung was sie dann mit
den zusätzlichen Mitteln des Bundes
machen können und hier noch mal mein
Hinweis auch ganz wichtig dass wir mit
den Strukturen des Handwerks auch
darüber sprechen wie wir die Situation
für Auszubildende und ihre Wohnsituation
verbessern können weil es hier nicht so
eine Trägerstruktur gibt wie bei den
Studentenwerken deswegen da auch noch
mal meinen ordentlicher Wunsch wo sie
immer Sie die Möglichkeit haben in den
Wahlkreisen darauf aufmerksam zu machen
dass dieses Geld nicht nur für
Studierende da sondern auch für Azubis
[Applaus]
und die nächste Frage Kassem Teresa
leben
Kassem Taher sali ist Mitglied der grüne
Position danke Frau Präsidentin Frau
Ministerin es ist ja gerade in der
Presse zu lesen dass sie ein Umdenken
beim Neubau sehen und zwar von
Einfamilienhäuser hinzu dass wir
Eigenheim Bestand mehr fördern dabei
sprechen Sie sich auch für eine stärkere
Finanzierung der Sanierungsförderung aus
was wir als bundesgrüne Fraktion sehr
begrüßen welche Maßnahmen plant das
Bauministerium jedoch über die bekannte
Bundesförderung hinaus und vor allem
Kommunen im mit Leerstand Anreize zu
schaffen dass junge Familien
Einfamilienhäuser besonders in den
ländlichen Regionen zu fördern
ja wir sind ja gerade im Austausch mit
dem Wirtschaftsministerium was ja für
den Bestand zuständig ist sie kennen ja
meine
Unterstützung für Ansätze jungen kauft
alt und wir loben jetzt gemeinsam Wege
aus wie wir so ein Programm dann auch
für die bestandsunterstützung
hinbekommen wir sind allerdings noch
nicht so weit dass ich ihn dazu ein
Ergebnis präsentieren kann die
Möglichkeit einer Nachfrage besonders
das Potenzial in Ostdeutschland ist in
der Hinsicht relativ groß wann wann ist
ihre Prognose ungefähr wann sie bereit
sind und in der Pipeline stehen können
Sie eventuell dazu eine Aussage tätigen
war jetzt im Herbstferien im Westhafen
Urlaub da gibt es auch ein großes
Potenzial für Belebung des Bestandes
insofern würde ich nicht sagen das ist
ein reines Thema von Ostdeutschland ist
ich kann die leider allerdings jetzt
noch nicht sagen wann wir da soweit sind
danke
vielen Dank und die nächste
Fragestellerin ist Anne König
an den König aus der Unionsfraktion
ja Frau Ministerin ich hätte noch eine
Frage zum Wohngeld und zwar ist es so
dass sie meiner Meinung nach da wirklich
Öl ins Feuer gießen wenn sie am Anfang
so euphorisch sagen dass es in ganz
vielen Ländern schon möglich sein wird
pünktlich im auszuzahlen da steht
anscheinend auch jede Kommune vor
anderen Herausforderungen bei mir im
Wahlkreis steht heute schon großer Hilfe
Ruf in der Zeitung und ich kann ihnen
eigentlich nur Fragen auch aus meiner
Kommune weitergeben und zwar sind sehen
die wie folgt aus ähm wie im stellt der
Bund sicher das angesichts der hohen
Erwartungen seitens der Bürgerinnen und
Bürger eine Kommunikation dahin gehend
Erfolg das Anträge erst nach einigen
Monaten zu Auszahlung kommen vor dem
Gesetz sind alle Menschen gleich und ich
denke im es ist auch wichtig dass Sie
doch den Anspruch haben sobald ein
Gesetz in Kraft tritt das allen Menschen
das auch dann zu Teil wird bzw die
Auszahlung dann auch rechtzeitig Erfolg
das ist völlig wenn sie sagen in eins
zwei Ländern ist das vielleicht schon
möglich im Januar aber ich denke doch
dass es zu noch mehr Frust auf dem
Rücken auch der Mitarbeiter in den
Verwaltung kommen wird wenn verzweifelte
Menschen vor ihnen stehen und welche
Antworten geben Sie denen
ich habe nicht gesagt ein zwei Länder
sondern eine große Anzahl von
Bundesländern wird im Januar die neuen
Bescheide rausschicken können und die
Bundesländer haben den Bund aber ganz
explizit gebeten dass wir keinen Ranking
machen und keine länder benennen die das
besonders gut machen bzw auch keinen
ranking-ländern die aus welchen Gründen
auch immer größere Schwierigkeiten haben
und ansonsten wenn Sie die Presse
verfolgen werden Sie sehen dass ich als
Bundesministerin immer kommuniziere dass
die Reform ab Januar in Kraft ist aber
das ist vor Ort natürlich in eine große
Herausforderung ist für die Behörden ich
habe selber auch wohngeldstellen besucht
habe das auch immer deutlich
kommuniziert dass niemanden Geld
verloren geht wenn es länger dauert in
der Bearbeitung und dass wir Härtefälle
natürlich die Möglichkeit gibt die
vorläufige Bezahlung zu machen und
ansonsten ist das natürlich so dass die
Situation in den Kommunen extrem
unterschiedlich ist diejenigen die jetzt
schon sehr lange Wartezeiten haben
werden größerer Herausforderung haben
als kommun jetzt innerhalb von wenigen
Wochen in der Lage sind das Wohngeld zu
bescheiden und wir sehen jetzt aber auch
schon dass viele Kommunen dabei sind
Personal aufzubauen Kapazitäten in
Berlin hat die Landesebene zum Beispiel
die Bezirke noch mal verstärkt mit
eigenem Personal das ist sicherlich sehr
hilfreich und sie haben die Möglichkeit
dann Nachfrage Frau König
um die Belastung in den Verwaltungen zu
reduzieren wäre ja auch eine
durchgehende digitale Bearbeitung
hilfreich gab es ihrerseits Gespräche
mit den Ländern hinsichtlich eines
einheitlichen Verfahrens
das ist eine ganz lange Geschichte die
Digitalisierung des Wohngeldes ist eine
der ersten Maßnahmen gewesen es gab auch
einen Verbund von Ländern die zusammen
digitale Lösungen entwickelt haben
schleswig-Holstein war das führende Land
und andere Länder insgesamt 11 haben
sich angeschlossen die eine
entsprechende gemeinsame Plattform haben
und wir haben auch noch die
Möglichkeiten übermittelt des ozg dazu
unterstützen wenn Bedarf besteht aber es
ist ihnen ja sicherlich auch bekannt
dass die Umsetzung von Bundesgesetzen
alleine in der Verantwortung der Länder
liegt und insofern ist es auch die
Entscheidung der Länder und ich werde
mich da auch nicht aufdrängen weil mir
das nicht zusteht als Bundesministerin
darüber zu entscheiden mit welcher
Fachanwendung Sie diese Bundesländer
umsetzen
ich habe jetzt noch
eine Nachfrage dann wenn der Herr
daltrupp zurückzieht habe ich noch eine
Nachfrage von Jan Marco Luczak und dann
würde ich die Befragung der
Bundesregierung beenden
mir macht das fragenspaß also
insbesondere auch deswegen
Frau Ministerin weil sie haben jetzt
gerade erwähnt dass die so viele
positive Rückmeldung aus den Kommunen
bekommen aus den Ländern bekommen dass
das alles so wunderbar klappt mit der
Wohngeldstelle dann frage ich mich aber
schon wieso der zuständige Ausschuss im
Bundesrat ein Entschließungsantrag
formuliert hat und wenn ich mit
Erlaubnis zitieren darf da heißt es eine
schnelle Umsetzung des Wohngeld plus
Gesetzes ist ohne gravierende
Vereinfachung des wohngedreht in der
Praxis jedoch unmöglich da sagt es dass
die Änderung der forschungsregelung die
Sie gerade so gelobt haben vorhin das
sei keine wesentlich Verbesserung die
Herabsetzung der Schwellenwerte
verhöhungsanträge konterkariert die
Bestrebung einer schnellen Auszahlung
und die Bagatellgrenze wo sie gerade ja
schon gesagt haben dass das
möglicherweise auch nicht ausreicht auch
da wird gesagt das ist zu niedrig wie
gehen Sie mit dieser Kritik um
aufgegriffen haben sie sie nicht
ja herzlichen Dank schön dass ihnen das
fragenspaß macht mir macht das auch Spaß
zu Antworten hier in der Runde und Sie
haben ja auch die Ausschuss des
Bundesrates verwiesen dann verweise ich
oft das Plenum des Bundesrates was ich
16 zu 0 dafür entschieden hat der
wohngeldreform zum ersten ersten 23
zuzustimmen
vielen herzlichen Dank dann beende ich
die Befragung der
Bundesregierung danke
für Alles Regierung die anscheinend auch
der Ministerin Spaß gemacht hat Klara
geil wird die hier doch recht
spontan kurzfristig eingesprungen ist
eigentlich sollte nämlich heute die
Bundesministerin für wirtschaftliche
Zusammenarbeit und entwicklungsferner
Schulze hier befragt werden das musste
aber krankheitsbedingt verschoben werden
und deswegen war eben hier
die Frage und Antwort den eingeordnet
hier folgt jetzt im Bundestag die
sogenannte Fragestunde da allerdings da
die Fragen oft vor schriftlich
eingereicht wurden und nicht hier dann
auch noch mal erläutert werden ist dass
wir uns weniger interessant zu zeigen
wenn allerdings ist hier mit der
aktuellen Stunde weitergeht dann werden
wir natürlich sofort wieder in den
Bundestag kommen denn es geht dort um
die Bedrohung durch Netzwerke von
reichsbürgern und rechts Extremisten auf
Wunsch der koalitionsfraktion gibt es
dort diese aktuelle Stunde und Grund ist
natürlich die Festnahme von 25 Menschen
vor einer Woche bei der unter anderem ja
auch hochrangige Mitglieder der
Bundeswehr waren frühere Offiziere und
auch eine ehemalige
Bundestagsabgeordnete der AFD jetzt aber
wie gesagt geht es erstmal weiter mit
anderen wichtigen Themen und die hat
Tina das dafür sie umrechnungsmaßnahmen
so ist es Katharina kühn die Staats- und
Regierungschefs der Länder der
Europäischen Union und der sogenannten
asian-staaten eine Vereinigung
südostasiatischer Nationen treffen sich
heute in Brüssel hier sehen Sie
ankunftsbilder von heute Mittag man
begeht ein Jubiläum seit 1977 45 Jahre
schon besteht die Partnerschaft zwischen
den Ländern die geographisch ziemlich
weit auseinander liegen quasi auf
gegenüberliegenden Teilen des Globus und
dennoch ist man vor allem seitens der EU
sehr an guten geopolitischen und
wirtschaftlichen Beziehungen
interessiert denn man will eine
Alternative aufbauen und fördern so
beschreibt es zumindest
Wirtschaftsminister Habeck eine
Alternative zu China um unabhängiger zu
werden von der Großmacht die Europäische
Union hat also ein großes Interesse
ihren Einfluss in der Asien Region zu
stärken und man will ein Zeichen setzen
mit dem Gipfel heute in Brüssel für
gemeinsame demokratische Werte in
geopolitisch turbulenten Zeiten
ungewohnter Besuch in Brüssel Staats-
und Regierungschefs aus dem
asiatisch-pazifischen Raum zu Gast zu
Beginn des Gipfels geben sie sich
zurückhaltend dabei existieren die
Beziehungen zu Region schon sehr lange
45 Jahre bereits nun sollen sie weiter
intensiviert werden
es geht um ökonomische Zusammenarbeit es
geht aber auch darum auf die Stabilität
in der Region zu schauen im Indopazifik
was können wir gemeinsam tun um die
Stabilität zu sichern aber es geht auch
zum Beispiel um die Lieferungen von
Produkten
wir freuen uns auf jeden Fall auf die
Kooperation mit Gleichgesinnten Ländern
wie ist die asiatischen sind bei
technologischer Kooperation z.B so
finden wir neue Wege mit neuen
Verbindungen
actions Verbindungen in eine der
dynamischsten Regionen der Welt mit
Ländern wie Singapur ein kleines aber
sehr reiches Land oder dem Schwellenland
Indonesien mit fast 280 Millionen
Einwohnern und zunehmender
Industrialisierung dort ist auch der
Sitz der asia-organisation mit dieser
Zusammenarbeit will die EU auch die
Abhängigkeit von China verringern hinzu
kommt
die assernstaaten haben ein
rieseninteresse dran dass die Macht des
Rechts auch die Macht des
internationalen Rechts gilt die
allermeisten verurteilen Russlands
Angriff auf die Ukraine wir haben
wirtschaftlich viel gemeinsam nehmen sie
einen wachsenden Markt in dem Land wie
Indonesien da geht es darum
Infrastruktur auszubauen da geht es
darum erneuerbare Energien
voranzubringen Einfluss gewinnen im
asiatischen Raum Absatzmärkte und
Lieferketten sichern das ist das Ziel
beim asiengipfel im globalen Machtkampf
der Systeme
und mein Kollege Michael krons ist für
uns in Brüssel beim eu-asien Gipfel Herr
krons lassen Sie uns erst noch mal so
eine Art Bestandsaufnahme machen wie
sieht es denn aus zwischen der Asien
Region unter den europäischen Ländern im
Bereich Wirtschaft im Bereich
Freihandelsabkommen
ja sehr unterschiedlich wir haben eine
Vergangenheit in der Vor einigen Asien
benutzt worden ist als
Produktionsort für europäische Firmen
für amerikanische Firmen all diejenigen
die dort hingegangen sind wollten mit
billig Arbeit die sagen wir mal
Fertigung von bestimmten Dingen
Textilindustrie etwa sehr günstig
produzieren und das war mehr oder
weniger ein sehr ungleiches Gewicht
zwischen Asien und Europa und den USA
wir haben inzwischen Staaten
Singapur ist schon angesprochen worden
die wirtschaftsstark sind die auch gar
nicht mehr produzieren sondern längst
Handel treiben und zwar auf gleicher
Augenhöhe und insofern hat man
inzwischen natürlich schon seit vielen
Jahren begriffen dass Asien nicht mehr
der Produktionsstandort alleine ist
sondern vor allen Dingen auch der Ort ja
um auf gleicher Augenhöhe miteinander zu
diskutieren und zwar nicht nur auf der
wirtschaftlichen Ebene denn heute geht
es vor allen Dingen um Politik natürlich
auch um Wirtschaft aber vor allen Dingen
und Politik es geht auch darum eine Art
alternative aufzubauen gegen oder ja
Alternative zur Großmacht China aber
ganz ohne China geht es ja auch nicht
wie sieht denn die china-strategie aus
und unterscheidet sich vielleicht die
europäische China Strategie von der der
Asia Asien Region
muss man erst mal Fragen gibt es
eigentlich eine China Strategie also
wenn man die China Experten in
Deutschland etwa fragt die sich mit dem
Thema Chima China beschäftigen und sagen
die ja ihr habt ja überhaupt keine
Strategie entwickelt in den letzten
Jahren wir haben ja jetzt das Problem
dass wir auf der politischen Ebene mit
China diskutieren sprechen müssen was
diesen furchtbaren Krieg in der Ukraine
angetrifft diese Aggression Russlands
und Russland hat sehr geschickt in den
letzten Jahren versucht auch in der
China sozusagen eine politische Basis zu
finden wir haben immer noch keine klare
Verurteilung dieses Angriffskrieges
durch China erlebt insofern China ist
nicht das alleinige Problem sondern das
eigentliche Problem ist die Komplexität
anderer asiatischer Staaten mit denen
man jetzt gemeinsam überlegen muss wie
bekommt man denn eine gemeinsame
strategische Position hin in der Politik
weil es ist völlig klar dass in den
nächsten Jahren ganz entscheidend sein
wird dass man mit asiatischen Staaten
zusammen etwa das Thema Völkerrecht
bespricht es soll eine internationale
Ordnung geben und diese internationale
Ordnung ist die Voraussetzung dafür dass
so etwas wie durch Russland nicht
passieren kann bzw dass ein Land wie